exact
[Musique]
le sait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa femme je suis de ctv news je suis
animatrice au soir notre network se
compose essentiellement d'électeurs
indécis ils sont ici même au coeur de
l'action sur le plateau il faut savoir
cependant que nous leur avons demandé
d'éviter d'applaudir pendant les débats
afin de favoriser par ce débat il faut
savoir également avant de commencer que
nous allons aborder cinq grands thèmes
ont été choisis en fonction des
questions que se posent les canadiens et
ils veulent que l'on débatte
nous avons reçu plus de vinification les
thèmes que ce soit donc c'est en
fonction de ces questions ces débiteurs
et y répondrons en entre qui a été ta
bible alors que tu iras chaussoy nous
voulons un débat digne de ce nom ce soir
le spectateur c'est pourquoi les chefs
se sont entendus pour respecter leur
temps de réponse ce soir
le premier thème leadership au canada et
sur la scène internationale la première
question de rigoler ici même dans
l'auditoire un grand nombre de canadiens
est ce que le canada est beaucoup plus
divisé maintenant vient le
protectionnisme américain à l'aube
réduit les tensions croissantes avec
youtube en tant que premier league avec
de fait comment il est entré vous les
intérêts et valeurs des canadiens sur la
scène internationale merci beaucoup
monsieur trudeau vous avez le droit de
parole en premier avec nous ce soir et
merci à vous tous et toutes de vous
joindre à nous en ce moment très
important pour parler de l'avenir de
notre pays et vous permettre de comparer
les différents programmes tels que nous
avons et nous vivons une ère est
difficile de protectionnisme sur les
quatre dernières années nous avons dans
les canadiens pour que les gens sont
optimistes le rapport est l'avenir pour
qui sait les outils pour connaître du
succès et aussi pour que leurs enfants
question oui nous avons surmonté les
défis qui nous avons bien sûr dix édifie
l'économie de demain
qu'est ce qui nécessite que nous les
autres chefs
ici c'est sûr des mondialistes ils
dépensent face à jean dyonis ce seuil
est aussi un jour au conseil de sécurité
des nations unies donne votre argent à
d'autres pays pour lutter contre le
changement climatique pour construire
des routes en afrique
l'onu est un organisme dysfonctionnelle
devant être en mesure de nous battre
pour notre pays
à l'heure actuelle nous sommes seuls
partie d'une politique étrangère
vraiment fondées sur une autre propre
sécurité et tout sur notre prospérité
maintenant j'ai tour a laissé beaucoup
les sans merci beaucoup ri gun pour
votre question et ça doit être difficile
de poser une question des enfants une
fois comme ça et merci au canada d'être
avec nous ce soir de cette section pour
moi le leadership a tout à voir avec
comment vous bâti et si vous devez faire
ce qu'il veut faire pour les gens et
qu'il s'agisse tu d'affaires
internationale de se tenir debout devant
le temps de négocier de meilleurs entend
commercial pour moi ça ce que tu as
qu'on a le courage pour se tenir debout
devant les intérêts puissants laisse
aussi les grandes sociétés qui ont trop
d'affluence au canada et jusqu'à présent
canada ce soit vraiment un conservateur
ou libéral n'ont pas eu le courage se
tenir debout
nous sommes différents je travaille pour
les gens a été en photos blake fait
affiche toujours un masque
il affiche un masque pour la
réconciliation il congédie son procureur
général autochtone i love congédié deux
de ces éminentes ministre s'est il le
prétend défendre la classe moyenne mais
monsieur trudeau vous êtes info vous
êtes double et vous ne méritez pas de
gouverner le canada conviés dans le
temps j'aimerais tout d'abord commencé
en reconnaissant que nous sommes sur le
territoire le tradionnel appelation
algonquine a une réputation donner à
tout et nous sommes un pays qui
défendent le mix il atteint
comme nation nous sommes engagés à
respecter les objectifs de développement
durable ce qui veut dire que notre
avenir dépend
il faut mettre fin à la pauvreté voire
encourager l'éducation des femmes et des
filles ça c'est tout ce qu'il pouvait il
faut également renégocié l'organisation
un mondial du colleur se faire en sorte
que l'on fasse la promotion des mesures
climatiques
nous avons besoin d'une organisation
internationale pour les migrations
climatiques
il faut également appuyé la suprématie
du droit à l'échelle internationale
puisque la question comme premier
rendez-vous les valeurs et intérêts bien
sûr je ne deviendrai a probablement le
premier ministre devant vous ce soir à
tous et à toutes de montrer du
leadership qui ne font que le fait
d'hériter de rui sur les producteurs de
porcs de ceux qui en paient le prix
quand on fait face à un pays puissant
kmmg la chine
on ne sait pas prendre force on
soutiendrait quelqu'un avec un véritable
leadership continu notre thème
leadership au canada sur la scène
internationale
c'est à mon tour de poser une question
au nom des canadiens qui étaient choisis
par tirage au sort la question suivante
s'adresse donc aux tous les autres chefs
ont ensuite eu l'occasion d'en débattre
avec lui monsieur vous aimez beaucoup
envoyer les des tweets le permettez moi
d'en lire à haute voix
vous avez qualifié la diversité au
canada de sectes et de multi réalisme
extrême
vous avez employé les mots ghetto et
tribus pour décrire les nouveaux venus
qui voulut cobol it pourrait semer la
méfiance est potentiellement la violence
hors du greta tonnes d'algues
la militante pour le climat
qui appelle 16 ans vous dire qu'elle est
perturbé mentalement ça j'étais là des
paroles d'une personne qui à l'intégrité
de mener le canadien nous a présenté sur
la scène internationale merci de votre
question écoutez il faut dire la vérité
aux vins notés si on veut diriger le
pays en ce que je dis au sujet du
culturalisme et multiculturalisme
extrême c'est que on ne va pas
construire mon pays comme ça nous devons
être fiers de notre pays oui du
multiculturalisme mais on n'a pas besoin
d'une loi pour nous dire qui nous sommes
nous sommes un pays diversifié nous en
sommes fiers
est ce que je dis au sujet de
l'immigration c'est tout simplement
qu'il faut au moins 10 microns et il
faut s'assurer que les gens qui arrivent
vont participer à notre société
nous avons un grand pays mais il est
temps de discuter du dossier des
migrations
nous voulons pas que notre pays soit
comme les pays européens on a beaucoup
de difficultés à intégrer les immigrants
moi je suis un canadien canadien fier de
son pays et je suis le seul chef ici qui
est prêt à discuter d'une longueur si
nous allons donc avoir un débat des plus
animées ce soir car c'est au tour de
monsieur sindh en débattre avec monsieur
bernier sur cette question à savoir le
tempérament d'un bon lunaire monsieur
bernier après l'avoir entendu ce qui
vient d'être dit vous auriez pu dire je
me suis trompé parce que c'est pas mal
aurait pas ce que vous avez dit vous ne
devriez pas de surprise je crois qu'un
leader n'est pas quelqu'un qui doit
diviser les gens qui doit les monter les
uns contre les autres c'est quelqu'un
qui tente de trouver des ponts les
rassembler c'est ça qui est un leader
fait leader est là pour les gens qui ont
besoin d'être voilà d'aider les gens qui
sont les plus riches les grognements
ottawa travaille depuis longtemps à
faciliter la vie aux millionnaires
à envoyer à donner des risques sont des
impôts société ce n'est pas la façon de
construire un pays il faut aider les
canadiens mais pas avec des moules à
paris personne parce que c'est lui à
tout le monde ce n'est pas ici il faut
de la croissance économique
ce dernier il faut redonner aux
canadiens selon des besoins
c'est parce que je me permets de vous
rappeler qu'il s'agit bien bel et bien
dans le débat mais que les spectateurs
ont des difficultés à comprendre que ce
soit si tout le monde parle en même
temps dans cette partie du débat on peut
en débattre avec monsieur bernier mais
maintenant c'est au tour de monsieur chu
d'en débattre avec monsieur bernier sur
la question du leadership
monsieur bernier n'a pas compris qu'on
peut être très fiable de l'histoire
canadienne on peut être fier de son
identité fiers de nos réalisations ici
et ailleurs dans le monde tout en
accueillant des gens de partout dans le
monde
c'est l'un des atouts
au canada les gens viennent au canada
grâce à pour notre liberté et pour la
liberté d'expression l'égalité entre
désormais monsieur bernier la liberté de
religion
vous avez changé avant d'oser vous
croyez dans ce système d'immigration qui
étaient justes équitables compatissant
et maintenant vous tirez votre
inspiration des parties les plus sombres
de la société oui mais écoutez moi ce
que je veux c'est un pays c'est un pays
je ne veux pas c'est des prises d'eau
chaude
oui vous pouvez le faire vous pouvez le
faire mais sans insulter ceux qui
viennent au canada
vraiment c'est la différence entre
monsieur bernier et moi nous croyons qu
on peut renforcer le canada en
n'augmentant notre population et en
célébrant tout aux réalisations sur le
même sujet j'ai bien compris la question
on lit ça vous avez également posé une
question sur les caractéristiques dont
il faut faire preuve pour faire plus de
leadership
le leadership c'est rendre le cerveau
qu'est ce qui fait un bon premier
ministre eh bien il faut le reconnaître
que nous sommes là pour desservir la
population générale on n'est pas là pour
dire quoi parlez vous servir la
population générale
bon tout à l'heure où jack qui va se
faire et éviter au parlement où on n'est
pas invité on essaie d'aller travailler
pour les gens et moi je crois qu'il faut
faire preuve de leadership dans le
service bon maxime bernier ce qu'il a
dit c'est vraiment épouvantable
il connaît mon opinion il sait on
s'assoit yale elle à côté de l'autre et
il sait que quand il parle à jeter vais
me tenir la tête entre les deux mais
parce que je vous invitais je vous aime
bien mais je ne ferai pas je vous cache
pas vos idées socialistes et vos
politiques
écoutez on ne sera pas capable de créer
des emplois avec votre politique ce sont
des politiques de pays socialistes comme
le venezuela
on ne crée pas de richesse admettez le
dans ces pays là il ne se crée pas de
richesse l'enjeu économique
vous avez un programme 60 milliards de
dollars ce n'est pas responsable
économie c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
la ville à l'immigration je viens
d'immigration que j'appelais migros yati
qui sont pro immigration c'est la même
source merci madame mais maintenant
monsieur blanchet aura l'occasion d'en
débattre avec monsieur bernier lui vous
allez me laisser combien de secondes
avant de me d'intervenir
bon quand quelqu'un kiev que la vérité
ne devrait pas nier
les changements climatiques et le mot
socialisme semble être un peu facile à
10 secondes
l'immigration n'est pas une question de
chiffres
c'est une question de ressources dans
lesquels on investit pour que ces
personnes se sentent les bienvenus au
canada et au québec en vue qu'ils
puissent se partager notre langue
partager certaines de nos valeurs et si
nous disposons de suffisamment de
ressources
cela est possible à réaliser en effet
pas en envoyer un message pour qu'il ne
se sente pas bienvenue au canada
et vous savez 49 % des sociétés sont
d'avis qu'il faut avoir moins de dix
migrants ne sont pas des racistes
pourquoi moi parce que je suis d'accord
avec la majorité de la population à la
majorité des canadiens et ce n'est pas
évident je n'ai pas raison nous avons le
soin de débattre des idées c'est ce que
ce faire vous a dit que vous avez le
droit aussi d éminemment sommes tous si
nous en sommes les sérères diminution
des canadiens pierre merci le dernier
débat sur ce sujet monsieur trudeau et
monsieur bernier le tempérament d'un
leader je pense qu'il est important de
reconnaître que le monde dans lequel
nous vivons est un monde où ces
discussions cette polarisation où cette
crainte de l'autre est devenu quelque
chose que certains politiciens décident
d'attiser lorsqu'ils veulent attiser
l'incertitude dans le coeur des gens ce
qu'ils veulent que les gens votent
contre des choses malheureusement
monsieur bernier ici ce soir joue ce
rôle
ils tentent de soulever la peur chez les
gens par rapport aux migrations qui se
déroule par rapport aux occasions
ce qu'être et la mondialisation chaque
jour nous avons la chance de redéfinir
ce que l'on entend par être canadien et
oui ça va évoluer oui ça va se
transformer au fil du temps au fur et
mesure que nous avançons
nous voulons vous joue à la roue de
diversité sont célébrées partout dans
l'eau doit aussi parler de notre
identité souligné qu'ils nous sommes je
suis canadien
je suis fier de l'être comme vous nous
avons construit ce pays ensemble et ont
vu que ce pays soit le même bilan 25 ans
et on l'a dorn pays
je veux discuter de l'immigration et ce
dernier autant entre 6 et 12 ans ce mot
suspect simplement de dire publiquement
ce que monsieur scheer pas seulement
personnellement pour cent des canadiens
veulent davantage d'immigrants seulement
6%
donc si vous ne voulez pas faire débat
vous ne prenez pas la même langue que la
population des bâtons de ce sujet studio
et sur scène nous voulons maintenant
entend la voix d'un autre canadien ce
soir car cette question est si complexe
à cette question bien de susan fernando
qui pose sa question depuis calgary une
fille bonjour je m'appelle suzanne
freinant dogues de calgary le plus
souvent les gouvernements provinciaux et
fédéral ne semble pas sur la même
longueur d'onde et ce tous partis
confondus
or la coopération est clé dans
l'atteinte de nos objectifs par exemple
les patients les droits des travailleurs
l'éducation les soins de santé comme
premier ministre comment ils sont sûrs
et vous un leadership fort tout en
collaborant avec les provinces et
territoires
merci aussi à fernando de calgary une
fois de plus par tirage au sort à cette
question s'adresse à monsieur bernier en
premier et ensuite tous les autres chefs
auront l'occasion d'y répondre
bon tout d'abord tout d'abord je vais
respecter la constitution je vais
respecter les provinces et c'est très
important je ne veux pas me mêler des
champs de compétence des provinces que
ce soit la santé par exemple puisque
c'est une compétence provinciale
et vous savez on va tahoua ne pouvons
pas régler tous les défis en matière de
santé pas compte qu'on peut faire c'est
transférer les fonds ou province et ce
que je ferai c'est ensuite laissé les
provinces s'occuper d'éducation
s'occuper de la santé
c'est ce que dit la constitution il y
aurait des transferts de la tps
les professeurs l argent pour répondre à
vous monsieur bernier et maintenant
c'est beaucoup
j'aimerais remercier suzanne pour sa
question d'abord en fait elle a formulé
plusieurs préoccupations
les choses sont de plus en plus
difficile elle a parlé des pensions des
soins de santé
j'aimerais me concentrer sur les soins
de la santé c'est une des préoccupations
majeures quand je rencontre des gens à
travers le pays
j'ai rencontré un jeune garçon qui a une
maladie chronique et sa famille doit
payer pour des injections des
médicaments et sa plus grande inquiétude
c'est d'être un fardeau pour son père et
sa mère qui n'ont pas les moyens de
payer les médicaments et les grandes
pharmaceutiques sont plus importantes
pour monsieur trudeau que la santé déjà
des gens nous allons instaurer une
assurance médicaments pour tout le monde
mais si c'est merci monsieur chez eux à
vous de répondre
les conservateurs ont toujours reconnu
l'importance de travailler avec les
provinces nous respectons la compétence
des provinces
mais nous comprenons qu'il faut
également du leadership à l'échelle
fédérale pour que nos projets voient le
voit le jour quelque chose comme le
commerce interprovincial
mais je voudrais dire aux électeurs
partout au pays
les premiers ministres provinciaux
n'auront pas à saisir les tribunaux pour
lutter contre la taxe carbone
cette taxe carbone augmente le coût des
biens essentiels les sciences le
chauffage résidentiel et l'épicerie et
ça va nous faire qu'augmenter après les
prochaines élections il refuse de dire
aux canadiens
quel sera le coût de sa taxe carbone
s'il est réélu le gouvernement
conservateur a abolit de votre question
le parti vert collaboration il faut
régler les problèmes ensemble on ne peut
pas être nous voulons un conseil de
gouvernement canadien avant le
gouvernement fédéral les revirements des
provinces et des territoires
et si les municipalités les
administrations locales et les leaders
autochtones l'ip la nation limiter les
inuit
tout le monde doit être réunis autour de
la même table pour que nous puissions
nous entendre sur les questions urgentes
comme les soins de santé l'urgence
climatique il faut travailler ensemble
comme adam mais merci monsieur blanchet
c'était voudrait petit si je me souviens
bien j'ai pris connaissance d'une étude
aujourd'hui éric 8 par monsieur montigny
disant que ce n'est pas uniquement un
enjeu québécois et provincial aussi si
on veut coopérer avec les provinces et
avec le québec
il faut donc respecter les champs de
compétence provinciaux et il faut
arrêter de faire certaines choses et
c'est une des demandes du québec
on ne veut pas que notre argent soutenu
en otage par le gouvernement fédéral et
re donner d'autre part au québec
assortie de conditions
il faut respecter les gens de compétence
des provinces et mercy james
à vous de répondre souligne de cinar
peur pendant dix ans il a décidé
d'arrêter de rencontrer les premiers
ministres des provinces et nous avons
remis cela au programme lorsque nous
sommes arrivés au pouvoir nous avons
renforcé leur pc pour toute une
génération
nous avons aussi signé des accords en
matière de santé historiquement investit
beaucoup dans les soins de santé à la
maison dans la santé mentale ont réussi
dans les infrastructures dans le
logement dans les transports en commun
partout au pays nous continuons à
travailler avec les provinces sur la
renégociation d'un à l'ena et tout le
monde lors de la renégociation jouer
pour la même équipe en quelque sorte
alors nous luttons sûr en fait l'enjeu
principal de notre de notre époque parce
que jason kenny dope foule et d'autres
leurs consommateurs ne veulent rien
faire en ce qui a trait aux changements
climatiques
nous on va être un gouvernement au
canada qui va lutter au nom des
canadiens contre les changements
climatiques exactement ce que nous
allons faire nous aurons un débat libre
sous peu nous allons maintenant changer
de sujet et permettre un chef de poser
une question à un autre chef sur le
sujet de son choix
encore une fois l'ordre a été déterminé
par un tirage au sort le premier chef
cette fois ci sera le chef du parti
néo-démocrate monsieur 5 vous avez
grandi ces dons pour monsieur trudeau
vous parlez souvent la façon dont les
consommateurs ont réduit les impôts pour
les plus riches et ont réduit les
services jeu l'accord avec vous ma
question et vous critiquer monsieur
harper sur ces cibles environnementales
vous ne les avez pas atteint vous même
vous critiquer monsieur harper sur les
réductions dans les soins de santé vous
avez fait la même chose vous vous avez
donné 14 milliards de plus aux sociétés
qui mesure un peu pourquoi vous laissez
tomber les gens qui ont voté pour vous
les premières choses que nous avons fait
c'est de réduire les impôts de la classe
moyenne et nous avons augmenté pour les
canadiens les mieux nantis le 1% et
après 10 ans d'inaction du gouvernement
harper sur les changements climatiques
en quatre ans seulement nous avons
réussi à atteindre 115 centres objectif
pour 2030
nous allons atteindre cet objectif ne
l'ont même surpasser mais ça ne s'est
pas assis nous allons en faire d'avant
en plantant deux milliards d'arbres et
aussi en donnant de l'argent pour que
les gens puissent rénover leur maison
on veut aussi que le canada soit un pays
à zéro émission est ici 2050 nous savons
à quel point il est important d'aller de
l'avant et à l'heure actuelle
monsieur scheer pour sa part a promis
que la première chose qu'il ferait
c'est qu'il allait écarter le premier la
première stratégie de lutte contre les
changements climatiques a eu le canada
au contraire nous allons avancer parce
que c'est ce à quoi s'attendent les
canadiens nous avons réussi à sortir des
centaines de milliers de personnes de la
pauvreté grâce à nos amis cependant les
familles grâce à la location indienne
pour enfants est d'ailleurs le npd
monsieur singh le voter contre certains
de ces mesures nous allons continuer à
aller de l'avant crée des emplois
sortir les gens de la pauvreté parce que
c'est ce à quoi s'attendre les qualités
c'est ce que nous allons continuer de
faire maintenant tous les chefs veut en
débattre sur cette même question pendant
quatre minutes juste le dire
nous regardons le bilan de ce
gouvernement est en réalité c'est canal
a dit qu'en 2017 les plus riches ont
payé moins d'impôts et ont accumulé plus
de richesse est un des plus gros
problème auquel nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui ce sont les paradis fiscaux
non seulement votre ministre des
finances a utilisé des paradis fiscaux
mais le président du conseil du trésor
également à utiliser des paradis fiscaux
comment pouvez vous dire aux canadiennes
et canadiens que vous n'avez pas
l'argent pour financer une assurance
médicaments lorsque vous vous avez des
ministres qui ne paient pas leur juste
part monsieur singh plus tôt
ou la ressemblance est frappante désolé
nous avons eu un combat que nous avons
mené comtés conservateurs et les néo
nazis les mines anti l'autre nous avons
me faire aux échappatoires fiscales que
veut rouvrir monsieur scheer il veut
donner des crédits d'impôts c'est mon
question l'organiser les mules entier
nous allons aller de l'avant nous allons
investir dans les canadiens trudeau nous
allons donner une occasion pour monsieur
chiffres de réponse vous avez dit que
les propriétaires de petites entreprises
des petites entreprises c'était des
fraudeurs et en même temps vous avez
protéger votre fiducie et vos amis
milliardaires
nous on veut baisser les impôts pour
tous les canadiens on a un crédit plutôt
une baisse d'impôts universelle qui
veulent donner des centaines de dollars
de plus et un couple moyenne intervenir
ce que vous faites pour faire ce que
vous dépensez vous dépensez non les
réductions d'impôts c'est pas des
dépenses ils m'ont tout le monde dépense
de plus en plus or on ne peut pas créer
de la richesse quand le gouvernement se
contente de dépenser de l'argent il faut
lé bonne politique pour aider les
entrepreneurs il faut que le secteur
privé puisse investir c'est le secteur
privé qui va devenir du papier brun
budget personne et c'est pour sa
complété par ces hausses d'impôts madame
et vous aimeriez intervenir monsieur
singh a souligné que monsieur trudeau
n'a pas changé les objectifs en matière
climatique
objectif qui avait été il faut le
répéter et je suis déçu parce que
je croyais les libéraux en 2015 ce
qu'ils disaient qu'ils allaient axé
leurs politiques sur les faits qui me
disent aussi du dos et on va perdre la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
avec ces objectifs là parce que ils font
fi des conseils du giec et des
scientifiques
ce soir nous sommes le seul parti si
nous avons un plan mission possible
c'est le seul plan il va réellement qui
nous permettra d'avoir une économie
carboneutre 2050
non vous statistiques ne sont pas
suffisantes
autre plat et le celui-ci quelqu'un
scientifique avec le rapport de conseil
dont 15,5 degrés comme réchauffement
vous adoriez dire ça pour quoi
et bien parce qu'ils vont encore la
survie de nos 11 ans heureusement pour
s'attaquer à la crise climatique dans
lequel nous sommes
il va falloir du courage pour lutter
contre les grands pollueurs et va
pouvoir se tenir debout devant les
lobbies du nobis devant lequel monsieur
trudeau s'est s'est agenouillé et il
faut cesser de verser des subventions au
secteur des lectrices frères sont
d'accord ce qu'un plan sur luge
changement climatique que doit être
c'est être ambitieux et réalisables et
permis les plans sur les changements
climatiques que l'on entend ce soir il y
en a un qui était qualifié de réalisable
et d'ambitieux par les experts c'est le
nom c'est celui que nous avons mis de
l'avant le plan de monsieur trudeau ne
marche pas tout coûte plus cher pour les
travailleurs canadiens
il a donné une extension aux plus grands
émetteurs
grâce à notre plan nous allons lutter
contre les changements climatiques à
l'échelle mondiale on veut exporter nos
technologies propres et aider d'autres
pays à réduire leurs émissions c'est
tout le temps dont nous disposons pour
ce débat libre et cela conclut ce
segment vous avez l'occasion de prendre
la parole il fallait intervenir alors
merci
c'est la conclusion de ce segment
[Musique]
bonjour je suis affirme branche de
postes canada
ce thème est le segment sur la
polarisation les droits de personnes et
l'immigration j'ai commencé avec le chef
de léo démocrates de jack betting
j'aimerais d'abord vous poser une
question sur la loi de votre campagne
porte sur le courage cependant vous
n'avez pas fait preuve de courage dans
la lutte contre la loi discriminatoire
du québec que cette loi interdit l'accès
à des impros précieux de personnes qui
comme vous cours des symboles religieux
succès du premier ministre
permettez-vous aux provinces de faire
preuve de discrimination contre leurs
propres citoyens ne joue pas tout comme
les autres chefs ici en train de faire
passer les intérêts de votre parti au
québec au détriment de vos principes et
des droits de l'égalité de tous les
canadiens vous avignon c'est pour le
moins évident aux gens qui me regardent
qui nous regardent que je suis j'ai un
signe religieux c'est quelque chose qui
me fait de la peine quand on se fait
dire bon on disait que je crois pas pas
faire certaines choses en raison de la
façon de mon allure est bon les gens
souvent identifier l'identité est ce là
et les gens québec se font dire parce
qu'ils les portent un voile qui ne peut
pas être un enseignant qui ne peuvent
pas travailler comme juge et je pense
que bon c'est longtemps et je pense je
suis contre cela ce que quand je vais au
québec tous les jours j je suis ici je
crois qu'il faut se battre contre les
changements climatiques
je crois fermement et sans équivoque à
au droit d'une femme de choisir et de
créer plus d'accès aux services
d'avortement et je veux qu'on s'attaque
aux grands sociétés qui influencent le
gouvernement et qui contestent notre
capacité d'aider les gens changent fait
ça tous les jours
messieurs je suis question d'abord
j'aimerais vous féliciter pour votre la
façon dont vous avez traiter ces
questions de race d'identité vous avez
été victimes d'agressions par le passé
on entendu des scandales de pendant la
campagne électorale également
c'est important de comprendre que nous
n'allons pas intervenir dans cette
affaire
le parti conservateur défend toujours la
liberté l'égalité les libertés
individuelles
nous nous étions pour ça juste des films
de cette discussion la polarisation bon
projet de loi 21 va enfin vous savez les
gens pays sont se font monter les uns
contre les autres
donc les gens qui ne peuvent pas trouver
un logement on ne peuvent pas payer
leurs médicaments ou le ou leurs
factures se font dire que ce n'est pas
la faute des gens des grandes sociétés
ou des gens qui ne plaît pas leur jeu
juste pas c'est la faute des immigrants
ou des réfugiés ou quelqu'un qui
travaille 12 heures par jour et voilà
pourquoi les termes importants pour nous
de nous attaquer à l'insécurité
automatique
merci monsieur à vous de prendre la
parole avec monsieur c'est sur la
question j'aimerais
l'italie les commentaires de m joue jane
mythe
dernièrement les choses ont été dites
rage nous sommes en période électorale
et nous avons vu plusieurs enjeux des
questions de privilège et toute personne
blanche à ce privilège
mais si on pense au projet droit 28e
cette fois au québec
c'est un défi pour nous tous comme c'est
le cas pour les néo démocrates le parti
vert s'oppose à ce projet de loi alors
on se pose la question quelle est la
meilleure façon un gouvernement fédéral
que le protéger les droits de la
personne au sein du québec
eh bien les québécois il ya certains
gros pour québec quiconque est ce que
cette décision devant les tribunaux il
est ce que je dois faire partie de faire
plus de discrimination et franchement
nous sommes dans une situation où nous
ne roulons pas nuire à ce déballage
intérieur que j'aimerais aborder
également non bien que le projet de loi
21 polarise les gens vous avez des bons
il faut s'attaquer aux grandes sociétés
qui ne paient pas leur juste pas et
c'est à partir des raisons pour laquelle
les gens ne peuvent pas bien gagner leur
vie ne peut pas trouver de logement ou
avoir accès aux médicaments dont ils ont
besoin parce que les gens les plus
riches ne paient pas leur juste part
mesdames et d'action à la merci monsieur
blanchet à votre tour bien plus que vous
êtes bien aimable soixante dix pour cent
de la population du québec appuie le
projet de loi 21 70 au sein de parlement
québécois l'appui également de ce n'est
pas une question qui polarise les
québécois et voilà le problème en
anglais est aujourd'hui soit clair
chacun ici a des problèmes avec l'idée
de la laïcité n'a pas vraiment de
traduction en anglais pour seulement
dans le meilleur des cas vous dites que
vous allez tolérer ce projet de loi mais
le québec n'a pas à se faire dire quoi
faire c'est sûr je suppose que je dois
ce qu'il dit que les gens raison de leur
apparence il ne peut pas faire leur
travail que c'est fou d'avoir ça et vous
avez dit que je blanche est ce qu'on
devrait faire ses blanches est plutôt de
faire cela on devrait dire protégeant
les droits des femmes a plus de
protection
que veut dire ressemble et d'un contexte
de laquelle je suis en haut des
protections à la communauté lgbt q quand
on est d'accord merci merci monsieur
blanchet monsieur singh messieurs tout
doux il monsieur singh peuvent en
débattre maintenant monsieur singh vous
avez parlé de façon fort éloquemment ce
jeu de la discrimination
il avait lutté contre les
discriminations toute votre vie et il
serait raison pour laquelle c'est si
surprenant de vous entendre dire comme
tout autre leader sur le sur la scène ce
soir c'est un événement fédéral sous
votre gouverne n'interviendrait pas dans
le cadre de questions du projet de loi
21 au québec oui bien sûr ça vous met
dans une mauvaise façon politique parce
que comme le dit monsieur blanchet c'est
très populaire au québec mais je suis le
seul qui soit sur la scène ce soir qui
est dit que oui il possible qu'un
gouvernement fédéral doivent intervenir
parce que le gone en fédérale doit
protéger les droits des minorités les
droits linguistiques 3 protéger les
droits des femmes et doit le faire
partout au pays
vous m'avez pas dit que vous auriez que
vous allez peut-être été revenir j'avais
laissé la porte ouverte à cette
possibilité
chaque jour de ma vie je le lance je
donnais l'autre noir maintien moi je je
je mets les gens défie tous les jours de
ma vie je je canalise la frustration des
gens il ya plusieurs déjà près de là
pays qui se fond qui se font dire on
peut pas réaliser telle qu'elle changera
raison de leur apparence ne pas agir en
fonction de vos convictions de premier
ministre d'accord merci monsieur bernier
vous pouvez en débattre avec monsieur
singh pour ce qui concerne
le projet de loi 21 on doit respecter la
constitution et au niveau fédéral
on doit respecter les décisions prises
par les gouvernements provinciaux sait
ce qu'on doit faire et autre chose
monsieur si vous dites que vous ne
voulez pas que je sois ici pour un
discuter de ces questions là vous êtes
en faveur de la diversité mais qu'en est
il de la diversité des points de vue des
opinions - j'ai le droit d'avoir une
opinion différente de la vôtre au sujet
de l'immigration
vous êtes un chef de parti vous voulez
que tout le monde vous suivent seulement
la banalisation je peux écouter
allez vous écouter les gens qui disent
des choses que vous voulez entendre
c'est tout je vais répondre
après deux ou trois minutes de ce débat
ce soir les gens peuvent voir clairement
pourquoi vous ne méritez pas cette
plateforme
c'est une chose de dire que vous êtes en
désaccord avec quelqu'un c'est pas un
problème mais quand vous inciter les
gens là je vais vite quand vous le
faites de façon à la rumeur parlait d'
instabilité mentale du jeune fille ça
démontre un manque de jugement vous ne
méritez pas un clac forme et je suis
heureux de vous mettre des filatures vos
idées sont nocifs pour le canada et moi
je suis imitée data mérigeau coup merci
monsieur bernier messieurs c'est un
continent avec deux thèmes de la
polarisation des droits de la personne
et les migrations des gens partout au
pays regardent ce débat y compris une
grande foule à l'immeuble de
l'association étudiante allure stylée
colombie-britannique nous avons
maintenant un public de vancouver à luzy
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir je suis prêt je
m'exécute je suis ici à l'inversé de la
beauce colombie-britannique ce soit mais
j'habite à courre stream en colombie
britannique
ma question porte sur la polarisation le
canada me semble plus utilisé que jamais
si la diversité est notre force
mais la division et notre faiblesse
commun allez-vous vous assurer que vous
avez une vision unifiée au canada et
vous assurer que toutes les voix de tous
les horizons politiques que soient
entendus et tenu en compte
merci vous avez 40 secondes vais-je
merci beaucoup de votre question je suis
reconnaissant d'avoir la chance de vous
parler quand vous parlez des divisions
que nous vivons dans le pays il y en a
plusieurs
elles vont en augmentant mais moi je
pense que plusieurs raisons il la
radicalisation
il ya des discours haineux il ya un
climat qui perd mon genre d'être plus
audacieux mais une des raisons c'est que
les gens s'inquiètent de leur avenir
il ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas
accès aux choses de base comme le
logement les médicaments et c'est
réellement la négligence des
gouvernements précédents qui nous a
menés là je pense que je pense qu'il
faut pour que les gens écrivent autre
chose
monsieur c'est très important de
comprendre pourquoi le canada est à ce
point multiculturelle c'est parce qu'il
ya des gens qui viennent de partout dans
le monde et qui viennent y élire
domicile ' pourquoi parce qu'ils
aspirent aux libertés individuelles chez
nous quels que soient leur génération
quelle que soit la région du monde
ils sont les bienvenus c'est important
de s'en souvenir de le promouvoir et de
veiller à ce qu'on écoule ses valeurs
mais voici ce qui est dangereux quand on
a un premier ministre comme justin
trudeau qui se sert de la race et des
paroles haineuses pour démoniser tous
ceux qui sont en désaccord avec lui
merci beaucoup monsieur c'est le genre
de chose qui sème la démission par tour
et bonsoir à vous colombie-britannique
jamais dit bonjour aux territoires moss
comme cb tous trois méchants
donc nous ne voulons pas que les gens se
tournent le dos aux politiques nous
devons ramener l'île et de la réelle
démocratie où chaque citoyen a le
pouvoir de travailler ensemble mission
possible c'est ce que nous disons pour
agir pour le climat il faut que tout le
monde mette l'épaule à la roue
nous avons besoin de tout le monde pour
cette époque la cie et il faut que les
élections soient faits de façon juste il
faut se débarrasser du système
majoritaire uninominal à un tour parce
que ça crée des rivalités moi ma mère si
l'élection il merci j'avais reçu
planchez oui bien je crois que la
démocratie est favorisée par
l'information donc quand on traduit voté
par des gens qui vous ressemble
mais pour le moins voté par des gens qui
vous ressemble physiquement c'est dans
le meilleur des cas malhonnête et
j'aimerais vous rappeler qu'en 2011 la
même phrase a été dit par michael
ignatieff est qu en 2015 a été reprise
par thomas mulcair
c'est tout le temps dont vous disposez
monsieur trudeau c'est 40 secondes pour
chaque chef s'est passé à 40 secondes
tout le monde a le même temps pour en
débattre
merci puis je votre question je serais
heureux devant tout le monde rigny
allures de conte biotechnique j'ai déjà
été moi-même oui
c'est vrai nous vivons une époque de
polarisation beaucoup de différences ont
mis en exergue par les débats que l'on
entend ici et par campagne électorale
mais la question savoir comment on va
aller de l'avant mais la réalité ce que
la plupart des canadiens sont d'accord
sur les mêmes sujets nous voulons élever
nos enfants dans un monde meilleur pour
eux on veut pouvoir payer pour leur
avenir on veut pouvoir avoir une
retraite confortable en vue créer des
débouchés pour nos voisins
voilà qui unit les canadiens partout au
pays le fait qu'il y ait cette politique
de peur et les divisions ce courant
politique qui est encore présent ici et
bien et sa mine tout ce que nous tentons
de faire monsieur bernier j'écoutais
quand il est question l'immigration on
ne parle pas de polarisation en fait le
canada accueille plus d'immigrants par
habitant que tout autre pays occidental
trois fois plus que les états unis
donc il faut en discuter c'est
l'équivalent de toute la démographie de
la nouvelle écosse tous les trois ans
toute la population de nouvelle écosse
qui arrive dans l'immigration au canada
au bout de trois ans alors il est temps
de parler de l'immigration est d'avoir
un système
c'est pourquoi il faut accueillir moins
d'immigrants et avoir des migrants qui
ont une valeur et commercialise
monsieur bernier nous allons maintenant
passer au face à face au suivi d'un
débat les bras nous allons commencer
avec le chef du parti conservateur
monsieur adou chez vous pouvez choisir
la question que vous voulez et la poser
au chef que vous souhaitez vous avez 30
secondes monsieur trudeau vous avait
contrevenu aux lois sur les tic à deux
reprises
vous êtes intervenu dans une affaire
dont les tribunaux ont été saisis vous
avez fermé les enquêtes sur votre
corruption et vous avez congédier les
deux seules personnes dans votre caucus
qui dénonçait vos actions simplement en
disant la vérité quand est ce que vous
avez décidé que les règles ne
s'appliquait pas à vous monsieur j'ai le
rôle d'un premier ministre et de se
tenir debout pour l'intérêt public et
pour les emplois des canadiens et
canadiennes c'est ce que j'ai fait ce
que je continue à faire chaque jour
pour la façon par laquelle j'ai
travaillé pour les canadiens c'est en
investissant pour eux voilà qui
contrastait avec votre vision
c'est à dire donner des réductions
d'impôts à ceux qui font quatre cent
mille dollars par année
vous donnez plus ce déduction d'impôt à
ces gens qui font 400 me plutôt que ceux
qui font 40000 vous offrir une réduction
d'impôt de 50 mille dollars
c'est plus que ce que font bien des
canadiens ou 15 et les mines anti avec
votre programme électoral mais
évidemment on ne sait pas c'est quoi
votre programme parce que votre
programme n'a pas de couilles dhabi
jusqu'à présent réfuté notre programme
électoral est publié depuis des semaines
nous avons travaillé avec le directeur
parlementaire du budget et nous avons
une vision qui mise de l'avant qui
différente de la vôtre parce que nous
décidons d'investir dans les canadiens
et canadiennes
vous faites comme votre prédécesseur
vous cachez votre programme des
canadiens et vous allez donner des
crédits d'impôt aux menaces et à
découper les services avaient réfuté et
les autres chefs peuvent intervenir
également sa éventé ces choses-là de
toutes pièces la moitié de votre
plateforme et même pas chiffré vous
faites des annonces sans détails et sans
chiffres c'est vous vous étiez aux
chrétiens comment vous allez qui calle
ces programmes là les taxes ont augmenté
il a eu la classe moyenne
nous avons rencontré les impôts pour
l'heure pour ça que vous avez voté
contre soit vous avez regardé les
canadiens dans les yeux et vous avez dit
que les allégations dans le groupe
étaient fausses vous avez dit que jodie
web os ne s'étaient pas adressés à vous
vous avez dit que vous n'avez pas
exercer de pression sur elle sait gérer
manche la responsabilité de tout premier
ministre est de protéger les emplois le
pdg snc lavalin s'est adressé à vous
vous êtes en train des ventes il sûr de
chauffe en train de se battre pour
savoir lequel est le pire pour le canada
il faut commencer à présenter qui sera
le meilleur pour le canada quand on
pense à ce que les canadiens vivent
actuellement vos petites réductions
d'impôts monsieur chez n'aideront pas
les lesquels les canadiennes et
canadiens à payer leurs soins de santé
ou le coût des médicaments qui peuvent
coûter des centaines de dollars par mois
les canadiens nous proposons et on veut
leur donner plus d'argent on note
d'abord c'est moi finir duction dépôt
pour nous allons faire économiser de
l'argent aux familles on va investir
dans les l'assurance médicaments on va
investir dans le service de garde
d'enfants
ça va permettre d'économiser des
centaines de dollars par mois aux
familles et les familles qui vont avoir
qu'un client ait moins de 70 milles par
année vont avoir accès à des soins
dentaires ce qu'ils voulaient faire
économiser 1240 dollars par année aux
niveaux trouvés seuls c'est toujours la
même question que les conservateurs ou
trouverez-vous l'argent avec elle on va
demander aux canadiens canadiennes les
plus riches ceux et celles qui ont une
fortune estimée plus de 20 millions $ de
payer plus d'impôts oui on croit qu'ils
devraient payer plus d'impôts vraiment
fascinant des parts et ceci chaque mais
fascinante propositions là parce que
nous avons la même position dans notre
budget lorsque le directeur
parlementaire du budget se pencher là
dessus il est quelle est la plus grande
incertitude lorsqu'une parlant de
revenus des plus riches
eh bien ils s'inquiètent que les cuirs
et chevaucher des avocats pour éviter de
payer ses impôts mais il faut voir ce
que le directeur parlementaire du budget
a dit parce que bon oui le quand il
avait dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour les
garderies pour abolir l'éclat scolarité
pour l'assurance médicaments mais bon si
on dit qu'elles ne se blessent quelque
part c'est parce que les puristes vont
embaucher des avocats parcours pour
éviter payer leurs impôts
mais c'est choquant n'est ce pas nous
sommes dans le plus beau pays au monde
ne donne en occident si vous êtes riche
vous avez cette application vous avez la
responsabilité de payer vos effets je me
souviens doit payer sa juste part
je me souviens que messieurs chers a
déjà évoqué le scandale decency lavalin
j'aimerais parler pour 3400 personnes
innocentes qui n'ont rien fait de mal
lorsque monsieur trudeau a essayé
trouver une solution bien sûr et si
épris de la mauvaise façon il admis mais
monsieur chien ce que vous faites c'est
que vous jouez votre vin tous là dessus
et vous non présente une idée que le
québécois est une province corrompue les
actions ont descendu les gens monsieur
biais de ce pays il ya des pertes à
sophocle à cause de vous il n'y a pas d'
excuses pour que le projet nice
interviennent mais d'affaires dont les
tribunaux sont saisis
si quelqu'un ne devrait pas pouvoir
profiter de il son poste et ses amis
justement je veux je veux je veux je
t'ai ajouté j'étais le seul chef qui a
dit qu'aucune entreprise ne peut être au
dessus des lois je suis le seul à avoir
tenu ces propos
je pense que c'est la seule chose qu'on
va se mettre d'accord
aucune grande entreprise au début alors
il semble y avoir unanimité sur ce beau
sujet voilà qui conclut ce segment merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
et je suis 6e de la colle du toronto
star
bienvenue au chef j'animerai le prochain
thème les questions autochtones
nous allons commencer ce segment du
débat choisis par tirage au sort
de par ma question ou conserver le chef
du parti conservateur a du chien
les voici monsieur nous avait dit qu'en
gouvernement conservateur se
concentrerait sur le concret dans ses
relations avec les peuples autochtones
du canada alors que vous poursuivez
votre corridor énergétique promis
comment allez vous concrètement
consulter accommoder et obtenir le
consentement du peuple autochtone et que
feriez vous lorsque vos plans entre en
conflit avec les droits et intérêts des
peuples autochtones g12 réserves des
premières nations dans ma
circonscription je reconnais
l'importance de tenir compte des droits
des issues du traité et du besoin pour
les peuples autochtones de participer à
l'économie canadienne
c'est la clé un gouvernement
conservateur
reveillez à ce que sa proposition pour
un corridor énergétique et tiennent
compte des préoccupations autochtone en
veillant à ce qu'un ministre du cabinet
soit responsable des consultations
autochtone contrairement au jugement de
la cour qui a déterminé que le
gouvernement actuel n'avait pas
correctement effectué les consultations
sur tmx
nous allons veiller à ce que les
consultations soient dynamiques nous
n'allons pas simplement cocher une case
nous allons tenir compte de ces
préoccupations légitimes mais il faut
également savoir qu'il nous faut pouvoir
réaliser de grands projets le devant de
consulter c'est d'entendre les
préoccupations des uns des autres mais
il faut aussi que nous sommes en jeu
voit le jour je trouve que c'est
horrible monsieur scheer que vous ayez
oublié le devoir de consulter c'était la
même chose pour le gouvernement un peu
eu aussi on comptait atteindre
dans le cas des nuits enbridge comme
c'est le cas pour le pipeline trans
martin on n'a pas respecté la convention
des nations unies pour le droit des
peuples autochtones je sais que vous
vous opposez cette convention aurait
déjà eu le débat le débat mais clin
d'oeil il faut entre autres l'article 35
de la constitution il faut consulter les
populations autochtones et passe juste
pour faire en sorte qu'elles soient
d'accord avec nous il s'agit de
consultation nationale nation nous
parlons de droits territoriaux
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
consentement préalable
rudd donner librement qu'ils en veulent
de ses projets à mettre de côté cette
décision du tribunal des droits de la
personne pour la porter cette question
devant les tribunaux comme famille et
udo alors qu'ils ont conclue en fait que
notre gouvernement a agi contre les lois
des enfants autochtones
nous devrons événement avec des dizaines
de clients de thomson qui voudrait que
ces projets voient le jour parce qu'ils
savent que c'est le cas sur l'occasion
en question ils savent que c'est comme
ça prosperi ça fait il faut qu on
définir ce qu'on entend par le
consentement préalable donné librement
monsieur blanchet vous le tour monsieur
je vous dire que vous vous les respectez
les champs de compétence des provinces
et du québec
mais quand il s'agit d'établir votre
corrida mix énergétique qui se traduit
par pipeline si on veut à ce moment là
vous ne craignez pas d'exproprier les
gens dans toutes les provinces
vous dites que la constitution vous
donne le droit de passer à travers les
provinces à travers le québec sans
l'approbation de la population
et je vous rappelle que le premier
ministre du québec et la population sont
contre ces pipelines tout c'est faux il
est question de tenir compte des
préoccupations autochtone et des
préoccupations environnementales en
amont pour qu'on puisse enfin permettre
au grand projet de voir le jour
au québec c'est l'indication électrique
contexte réglementaire et vous le savez
autant que moi
les québécois achètent beaucoup
d'énergie aux états unis je pense que
les québécois mais vous avez du vrai que
le québec les niveaux 18h il faut pas
d'énergie américaine c'est ce que j'ai
fait mon choix
monsieur bernier puis je vous rappeler
que l'on parle du respect des droits
autochtones
monsieur trudeau merci nous nous
rappelons le règne de dix ans de cinar
pour lequel il n'a pas respecté les
règles du droit autochtone et les
peuples autochtones et vous monsieur
chiffres vous mettez de l'avant
exactement la même stratégie qui n'a pas
servi les peuples et les collectivités
autochtones et leurs enfants un plan en
vertu duquel peut en fait pas de projets
énergétiques a été construit nous devons
respecter les peuples autochtones ne
vont respecter la diversité d'opinion et
le tout doit être fondée sur la
déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones laquelle
vous écartez par l'entremise de vos
actions ce n'est pas respectueux des
personnes autochtones pour burger qui
est à la tête de l'assemblée des
premières nations a dit qu'aucun
gouvernement a davantage fait pour les
personnes autochtones que notre
gouvernement et il est temps de vous
comme étant monsieur chéri vous avez
raison il adorerait vous parlez oui il
va vous appeler mon numéro de téléphone
moi je n'ai pas de leçons à tirer de
monsieur trudeau il a congédié la
première procureur général autochtone
pour avoir fait son travail elle dit
qu'elle ferait les choses différemment
et vous l'avait congédié
quand elle justement fait les choses
différemment vous parlez de fa
construire des pipelines vous en avait
annulé 2 et celui que vous avez acheté
vous n'arrivez pas à le faire construire
vous avez déçus des dizaines de milliers
de personnes en alberta et en
saskatchewan et vous avez omis de
reconnaître que les communautés
autochtones
parsys de vous ici parce que je n'ai pas
de critiques
d'après certains que parce que j'en ai
marre d'avoir d'autres dont parlerons
nous y revient premier super bien
vous avez dit que vous étiez prêts à
construire des pipelines partout au pays
les laisser construire par le secteur
privé en parallèle vous avez dit que les
québécois étaient prêts à acheter du
pétrole et du gaz canadien je suis
d'accord avec vous lorsque dit que les
québécois savent que c'est plus sûr de
transporter cela par pipeline que par
très mais en même temps le gouvernement
du québec lui a dit qu'il n'y avait pas
d'acceptabilité sociale pour la
construction de pipelines ou québec est
votre position pensez vous que vous
pourrez le avoir recours à la
constitution parce que après
consultation qu'il n'y a pas d'accord il
faut pouvoir évoquer 92 10 de la
constitution pour pouvoir construire un
pipeline
aurez-vous la compétence les pouvoirs
pour approuver cela vous dit oui je vais
construire des pipelines
mais allez vous avoir le courage d'avoir
de recourir à la constitution pour la
postérité l'unité du pays non j'ai
toujours dit que le gouvernement fédéral
doit défendre sa compétence
nous respectons la compétence
provinciale quand on a la marine et je
suis convaincu que je peux obtenir
l'adhésion de la population et que parce
que les québécois sont favorables à
l'énergie canadienne les québécois
savent que c'est mieux de consommer de
l'énergie de l'ouest canadien que
d'avoir des pétroliers dans le fleuve
saint-laurent ou d'importer et de
l'énergie de donald trump et en plus on
va pouvoir laisser faire acheminer par
litre il est souvent présente le
tribunal des droits de la personne du
canada a conclu que le rendement de
monsieur trudeau a fait preuve de
discrimination envers les enfants
autochtones qui ne recevaient pas un
financement égal il ya eu une décision
qui dit que ces enfants devraient avoir
le même financement et ensuite monsieur
trudeau et son gouvernement vont faire
appel de cette décision
il voulait travailler fort pour garder
snc la valeur hors des tribunaux milva
il va traîner ces enfants-là autochtones
dans les tribunaux
ça fait c est heureux comment peut-on
faire cela cette décision aura des
implications profondes sur les services
de l'état à l'endroit des canadiens
autochtones
c'est un règlement très imposants et
quand il est question de politique
publique importante c'est légitime de
dire qu'il ya un contrôle judiciaire
mais je veux parler d'une autre chose on
parle d'enjeux autochtone j'suis à la
grèce et d'un rose récemment une
communauté bien sûr qui est touché par
un empoisonnement au mercure et il ya eu
une campagne de levée de fonds privés
mais monsieur tron doit être inscrit
pour votre don quels sites de premier
ministre et cela j'aimerais bien avoir
c'est une réponse à votre question
non mais là tout le temps qui nous est
ce que pour cette partie du débat débat
libre est terminée mais nous poursuivons
sur notre thème des affaires autochtones
nous avons une question d'un membre de
l'auditoire ici même agathe anne k tino
natacha biti a laissé natacha
bonsoir en tant que membre de la
première nation pour soleil ma question
est la suivante si vous êtes élu comment
vos parties collaboreront t il avec les
provinces et territoires sur la
reconnaissance et la réaffirmation des
droits autochtones notamment à la
lumière de la déclaration des nations
unies sur le droit de la personne
la commission de la vérité et de la
réconciliation et c'est un appel à
l'action et elle est la commission sur
les femmes autochtones et les femmes et
les filles autochtones disparues et
assassinées
merci pour votre question évidemment
difficile de répondre à cette question
là en 40 secondes dans ce rapport sur
les femmes et les filles autochtones
disparues et assassinées ya beaucoup de
recommandations y compris lutter contre
la traite des personnes c'est très
important
de plus on soutient la protection des
langues autochtones
le gouvernement fédéral un rôle à jouer
pour protéger ces langues qui sont
menacées de disparition
on peut les préserver maintenant je
voudrais parler de la déclaration des
nations unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones
quand il est question du consentement
préalable et donner librement
on ne sait pas exactement ce que ça veut
dire il ya beaucoup de communautés
autochtones qui veulent que ces projets
énergétiques soient réalisés il nous
faut plus de détails il faut bien
définir ce qu'on entend par là d'accord
nous passons maintenant madame ait
maigri
c'est une question extrêmement
importante que vous venez de poser et
tous les candidats du parti vert sont
derrière ceci nous allons respecter la
déclaration des nations unies pour la
protection de la protection des
populations autochtones
nous allons les appliquer dans ce pays
on a parlé de des lois qui le présente
une violence structurelle dans la cale
sur des femmes et filles autochtones
disparues et assassinées il faut
absolument respecter cette déclaration
des nations unies
il faut respecter ces recommandations et
les appels à l'action de la commission
de vérité et de réconciliation scellée
par un projet à court terme nous les
canadiens colonisateur devons assurer la
justice la déclaration
j'ai passé de bons moments au cours de
cette campagne avec des représentants
des peuples autochtones
ces peuples autochtones constituent des
nations tout comme le cannet le québec
au canada et donc il s'agit d'une
question de culture de langue de
patrimoine années et qui se retrouvent
dans les mains d'une autre nation donc
ils doivent revendiquer ses droits ne
représente pas mieux qu'il pouvait se
représenter lui-même en dépit des
enquêtes et de toutes ces enquêtes qui
ont été fait auparavant mais c'est
respecter ces peuples
merci natation de votre question nous
avons fait progresser la réconciliation
plus que tout autre gouvernement avant
nous mais je suis le premier à
reconnaître qu'il y reste encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire
nous avons levé 87 avis d'ébullition de
l'eau et les 50 qui resterait ça va se
faire ou si nous continuons à investir
dans les différentes collectivités
en ce qui a trait aux services et aux
enfants en famille nous reconnaissant
nous reconnaissons que comme le dit
tribunal que les enfants doivent être
indemnisés ils seront indemnisés mais
nous allons aussi mettre fin à la
tragédie en faisant adopter des lois
pour que les enfants les adorent
collectivités avec leur langue leur
culture
nous allons améliorer les choses agréé
cinéroc nous allons mettre de l'avant un
centre de traitement et nous aurons ni
fonds nécessaires pour ça mais ce
dernier
notre chef est prêt à vraiment nous est
de nouveau lié avec les premières
nations ils sont tous en faveur du statu
quo or le système actuel ne fonctionne
pas on continue à avoir des réserves
extrêmement pauvres
il faut une réforme vraiment courageuse
et notre parti est le seul qui va
justement accordé des droits de
propriété pour les résidents de réserve
et mettre en place le nouveau régime
d'autonomie pour ces communautés
il faut un nouveau système il faut
travailler avec les autochtones
mais les autres n'en veulent pas et on
ne peut pas réparer le système charge
d'une réforme vraiment courageuse et
nous nous société merci natacha pour
votre question c'est une question de
respect et de dignité
tous les ans je vous avez soulevé
reviennent à cette question de respect
de dignité
une des premières choses que nous
ferions on ne prendrait on ne traînerai
pas les enfants autochtones devant les
tribunaux et contester une décision qui
fait suite à une discrimination
nous avons de riom immédiatement les
questions de justice qui veut dire
mettre en oeuvre toutes les
recommandations de rapport ces
recommandations puissante qui en
apportent des solutions jeu j'assurais
une eau potable propre on n'a pas d'
excuses je m'assurais d'un logement
propres de qualité une éducation et des
services d sociale on peut rire
nous avons maintenant du temps pour un
autre débat en face-à-face sur n'importe
quel sujet et pour commencer et la chef
du parti vert elizabeth may vous madame
mais je crois que vous avez une minute
on a pendant des questions autochtones
et reconnaissons que l'assemblée des
premières nations nous dit que leurs
préoccupations prises par la ce moment
c'est l'urgence climatique nous devons
absolument nous concentrer sur des
solutions concrètes
vous ne pouvez pas avoir des plus belles
paroles que monsieur shihri avec tout le
respect qu'ils faisaient du monsieur
singh s'est pas seulement de beaux
discours ici il faut parler d'objectifs
et de sciences et pour ce faire il faut
l'idiot de 60 pour s'alléger es une
fille d'immigrants de parler de 28% par
exemple pour ça est-ce que vous monsieur
tu dois aller vous joindre à nous mais
dans un cabinet où l'on met de côté la
partisanerie un cabinet ensemble ou dit
que nous allons agir en sable pour
protéger l'avenir de nos enfants à
marolles nous reconnaissons que les
cibles sont importantes et nous allons
les surpasser ses objectifs mais les
cibles ne sont pas un plan nous avons
nous un plein qui a livré la marchandise
au cours des quatre dernières années
nous allons sous peut bénir et interdire
les plastiques à usage unique
nous allons mettre en place un plan qui
retourne de l'argent dans les poches des
canadiens
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
chine la plupart des canadiens sont en
meilleure position grâce à cette
tarification de la pollution ça ne sera
pas le cas si lui il forme le gone
hommes après les élections et met au
rancart notre plan nous allons continuer
à faire ce qu'il faut faire pour que les
canadiens avancent nous avons un plan
réaliste ambitieux réalisables selon ont
besoin les canadiens parce que si on
n'agit pas sur les questions
environnementales et bien les
conséquences seront désastreuses ne pas
avoir un plan pour notre avenir
faire en sorte que ce sont des enfants
et d'amis subiront vous pouvez
maintenant lancer le débat libre
vous avez une trois minutes et 35
secondes les données scientifiques sont
claires
votre objectif va mener à l'échec mais
c'est faisable nous pouvons faire
quelque chose vos objectifs ne respecte
pas les recommandations du giec le
génétique il faut s'éloigner
combustibles fossiles et franchement
vous avez acheté un pipeline vous ne
pouvez pas être leader qui défend le
climat et vous dépenser des milliards de
dollars sur un projet qui nous conduit
qui je passe là nous avons 1
là nous avons réalisé les canadiens ont
besoin qu'on agisse de façon elle nous
mettrons bien posture est nous qui nous
permet de lutter contre l'environnement
de créer une meilleure économie pour nos
enfants avec tous les respects autonome
ont fait davantage au cours des quatre
dernières années que non non non non mon
bar à vin au palmarès de ce fort à faire
mais personne ne se souvient du clan de
2007 paul martens est nommé en plan mais
la réalité c'est ou ozil autres
dernières années nous avons respecté la
naissance
il suffit pas de répéter quelque chose
ça veut pas dire que c'est vrai en le
répétant il est temps que vous appreniez
cela monsieur chiffre il n'y a pas de
canadiens qui pense qu'on aura plus
d'argent en payant une taxe carbone vous
avez des données de grande extension
plus grands émetteurs et votre ventre et
et j'ai déchiré tous ont dit que 80 %
des canadiens sont en meilleure posture
en vertu de notre règle en fait
confiance à vos films vous ne voulez pas
agir par rapport aux changements
climatiques
vous avez promis de baisser les impôts
vous voulez mettre au rancart le seul
que nous avons joué équilibrer le budget
voilà il ne me reste plus le temps son
plan est un échec à la fois s'il vous
plaît la vie coûte plus cher la nuit je
veux dire quelque chose directement
canadiennes et canadiens
vous n'avez pas choisir entre monsieur
retardé et monsieur déni il ya une autre
option qui existent nous sommes cinq
engageant un un vrai plein on va sévir
contre les grands pollueurs
il va falloir s'attaquer aux plus
puissants vous falloir qu'il est en
mission mais le plus droitier qui
huaient décès
les des objectifs poursuivis et l'avenir
des enfants je veux je sais pas je veux
dire quelque chose
écoutez les canadiens doivent savoir que
monsieur trudeau échir dont la même
position ils veulent imposer une
tarification du carbone d'un côté ou
encore d'autres c'est d'autres la pire
jeu zurich alors vous êtes semblables
vous allez finir les gros émetteurs vous
avez la même position à l'égard de ce
dossier un terrain d'entente
quand on sera à la chambre des cubains
vous vous appuyer un projet qui encore
une fois dépasse le budget carbone et
vous imposer ce projet aux québécois un
projet qui viennent ici parce que j'ai
déjà donné des réponses ce sujet oui
quand on prend cette idée de péréquation
basé sur les six missions de gs ce qui
dépasse la moyenne doivent payer la
péréquation et les autres qui sont en
dessous de leur faire travailler
ensemble avec tout le respect qui vous
ai dit c'est la question que j'ai posée
monsieur trudeau est ce que vous êtes
prêts à accepter le changement du statu
quo on change la façon de plans de
l'édition qu'on est un cabinet interne
au cabinet de collaboration et de
consensus et après c'est tout le temps
qui nous reste c'est à ces messieurs où
elle a tourné le temps qui nous reste
voilà qui termine cette partie du débat
merci beaucoup nous passons au débat sur
[Musique]
bonjour je suis donnant crise n de globo
news
je serai la modératrice pour le segment
sur l'abordabilité la sécurité du revenu
avant commence et je dois dire que vous
avez été très animée dans vos débats vos
commentaires ont été un peu long alors
il faudra peut-être réduire un peu le
temps mais nous allons nous assurer à ce
que ce soit juste égal pour tout le
monde alors sur ce sujet madame mais
j'ai une question pour vous la dette des
ménages au canada se chiffre à 2
trillions de dollars
le canadien moyen doit une soixante dix
neuf pour chaque dollar de revenu gagné
après un beau la dette n'a jamais été
aussi élevé nous empruntons pour les
dépenses communes de tous les jours mes
parents mon tour je dis que ce n'est pas
une bonne idée
madame m comment allez vous avez fait
une promesse audacieuses soient de
rééquilibrer le budget en cinq ans
pouvez vous y arriver sans causer encore
trop de difficultés pour financière des
canadiens que sera votre politique
précision qui permettra de réduire la
dette des ménages le parti est le seul
parti zik et qui a une bonne plate forme
avec les chiffres budgétaires d'autres
patrons mais chiffrés et du budget a été
approuvé par cavendish
ils sont l'institut pour la démocratie
la seule façon de mieux aider les
canadiens donc les les garderies on veut
abolir les frais de scolarité on veut
investir dans l'éducation post
secondaire
il ya des programmes dentaire pour les
canadiens à faible revenu
l'assurance médicaments toutes ces
choses là ça pour rendre leur vie plus
avantageux donc il faut avoir de
l'avenue ailleurs donc les paradis
fiscaux à l'étranger une taxe sur les
transactions financières une taxe de 1%
sur les personnes 5 sur la fortune pour
les personnes qui ont plus de 20
millions de dollars de richesses alors
plusieurs mesures comme cela pour la
voir davantage de revenus au
gouvernement du canada
donc bien sûr ça c'est d'après
l'institut la situation économique
actuelle
si jamais il y avait
les sessions se serait pas une question
d'idéologie l'équilibré budgétaire mais
en ce moment oui on est censé monsieur
blanchet cinq ans à vous d'en débattre
avec madame mais c'est vraiment une
mauvaise idée de remporter pour payer
l'épicerie et ce n'est pas une meilleure
idée que de faire des compressions taupe
importante dans les services socialement
pour les gens qui en ont le plus besoin
on pourrait éliminer toute subvention
aux grandes pétrolières comme ce que
nous proposons faire grâce à un projet
de loi c'était faire et on en a discuté
pendant la question sur la péréquation
cela permettrait de renflouer les
coffres du gouvernement
qu'en est il des objets fiscaux et
compris les deux nouveaux qui ont et
écrire par monsieur trudeau et qu'en
est-il de percevoir des impôts des
gaffes d'accord oui absolument dans
notre plateforme
on veut imposer les géants du web amazon
google et facebook
ces entreprises qui le tire des millions
de dollars dans ce pays sans payer
d'impôts il nous sommes d'accord avec
vous il faut cesser de subventionner les
combustibles fossiles c'est une promesse
qui a été fait par monsieur harper 2009
à l'origine mais c'est tout le contraire
on a fait davantage de subventions pour
le gnl
j'aimerais bien vous entendre parler un
peu de gnl québec on restait palace
également tous les combustibles fossiles
envisager une vie parce qu on est encore
à fond et je dois vous intéresse
monsieur trudeau à vous d'en débattre
avec madame mais sur la tête lorsque
nous avons décidé d'investir dans les
canadiens plutôt que lui et cette
décision des vaisseaux dans les classes
moyennes et investit aussi dans ceux qui
veulent se joindre la classe moyenne a
permis de sortir 900 mille personnes à
pauvreté inclure trois cent mille
enfants nous avons investi dans plus
d'étudiants pour qu'ils puissent aller à
l'école
j'investis dans les personnes âgées et
grâce à cela nous avons fait croître
notre économie plus d'un million de
nouveaux emplois ont été créés la
plupart d'entre eux à temps plein au
cours des quatre dernières années
en même temps nous avons réduit la
pauvreté et nous avons surpassé toutes
les cibles qui avait été mise de l'avant
nous l'avons fait de façon responsable
les agences de crédit nationales ont
donné une cote de crédit triple a cédé
la parole à madame mais dans tous les
débats et je suis certain que d'autres
chefs ici sont inquiets on a on n'a pas
le temps pour parler des soins de santé
et des coûts des soins de santé dans ce
débat alors je veux que nous parlions de
la question de la potabilité la vie
devra être plus abordable pour les
canadiens si on avait une religion
universelle d'assurance médicaments
c'est dans la plate forme ça dans la
plate forme de missions signe il faut
effectivement ça pour des soins de santé
ont baissé le coût des médicaments ou
même voler c'est ce qui est unique c'est
tout le temps dont vous disposez à vous
d'en débattre ou et monsieur bernier
tout à feu tout à fait écoutez regardez
votre programme je l'examiné elisabeth
60 milliards de dollars c'est ce que
vous allez lui dépensé sans créer de
richesses on ne peut pas lui créer la
prospérité à partir de riez il faut que
le secteur privé sentir et investissent
on sait que nous avons encore des
difficiles
monsieur trudeau vielles d'ajouter 17
milliards de dollars à la dette et vous
vous allez en ajouter 60 milliards
écoutez c'est irresponsable
ce sont nos enfants qui vont payer la
note dans le secteur privé lorsque vous
étiez dans le cabinet de mr il ya eu des
réductions fiscales pour les grandes
entreprises on l'a dit que cela a créé
des emplois mais ces grandes entreprises
n'ont pas investi dans l'économie sont
assis sous des piles d'argent et c'est
de l'argent qui n'a pas investi ça ne
sert à rien alors il faut mettre la main
sur cet argent là pour investir
nationale de faire bouger les listes et
d'une petite pays à l'autre ce un
pipeline
il nous faut ce réseau d'électricité
pour desservir des besoins de toutes les
provinces ce que je
c'est que vous ne voulez pas de
subvention pour l'industrie du gaz et du
pétrole et moi je ne crois pas aux oies
c'est des cadeaux de ce genre vous
vouliez changer la discussion vers les
soins de santé c'est un une des
préoccupations principales les
canadiennes et canadiens ne peut pas
avoir accès aux médicaments dont ils ont
besoin aux soins dentaires dans mon
bureau à abu dhabi j'ai une dame qui est
venue elle était gêné parce qu'elle
avait perdu des dents en raison de
manque de soins qu'elle ne pouvait pas
se permettre et ça c'est ça me brise le
coeur
madame et vous êtes prête à le faire le
problème c'est que monsieur trudeau n'a
pas le courage de s'attaquer aux
lobbyistes de l'industrie pharmaceutique
un mois je vais le faire si vous votez
pour les nîmois nous démocrates
on va s'assurer que ça se passe on
travaille pas pour les riches et pour
les grandes sociétés
on travaille pour vous on travaille pour
les canadiennes et canadiens on va vous
livrer la marchandise
il faut re négocié un nouvel accord de
santé c'est l'accord auquel on n'a pas
touché depuis trop longtemps
il faut revenir à la table dans ma
circonscription bon je gagne de débattre
à l'échelle locale vous fait tout ça
pour vous monsieur blanchet je n'habite
pas de candidat la plupart d'entre vous
avait d'excellents candidats dans ma
circonscription j'étais battu récuse
cette semaine sont excellents candidats
mais s'il ya une chose que nous avons
tous entendu ce que nous souffrons il
n'y a pas suffisamment de mixer une
famille il faut investir dans les soins
de santé
ça ne fonctionne pas en ce moment il
faut investir au sol et à vous la
possibilité d'un débat la question porte
sur le coût de la vie mme et
l'endettement des ménages
le thème principal de notre plateforme
c'est de donner plus d'argent aux
canadiens c'est qu'ils en aient plus
dans leurs poches
notre baisse d'impôts universelle va
donner 852 $ de plus dans les poches
d'un couple moyens on voit également des
taxes et les prestations de maternité en
un crédit d'impôt pour le transport en
commun et on a également un crédit
d'impôt pour les rénovation
écoresponsable émission pas du tout ça
c'est tout le contraire
voici comment on va payer nous voulons
réduire l'aide internationale du canada
de 25% on va cesser d'envoyer de
l'argent aux pays qui sont bien nantis
on veut ramener cet argent-là au canada
pour que les canadiens puissent
améliorer leur situation
inexistante
l'idée de sabrer dans l'aide donc
c'était une lettre que j'ai récusée
développement durable de l'onu il faut
mettre fin à la pauvreté au canada et à
l'échelle internationale c'est quelque
chose que nous pouvons faire dans la
prochaine décennie
mais on ne pourra jamais y arriver si
nous avons je pense que la course et pas
nous égoïste de mettre l'argent dans les
ouvrages amendes les portes vous
intéresse
nous avons un terrain où que nous
puissions entendre un autre canadien sur
le thème de l'abordabilité un endroit où
on ne s'écoute ce soir et à yellowknife
dans les territoires du nord-ouest
voici ce qui se passe au restaurant
coprah hausse nous avons entendu une
question sur l'abordabilité du score
mancelle un peu plus tôt bonjour mon nom
scott martin ailleurs l'unef
la question de la suivante que fera
notre parti au chapitre de l'inégalité
du revenu et de l'abordabilité au pays
je suis déjà allianz restera là bonsoir
yellowknife je suis ravi de vous voir à
nouveau il faut absolument agir pour le
l'équité du revenu l'écart entre les
riches et le canadien moyen continue de
se creuser
nous demandons d'avoir une commission
sur la fiscalité n'y a pas de bonnes
commission sur la fiscalité depuis les
années 60 il faut cette commission qui
se penche sur le code fiscal pour 7
code fiscal qui est toujours progressif
il faut éliminer ces allègements fiscaux
pour les grandes entreprises
faire en sorte que ce soit les canadiens
qui en ont le plus besoin qui s est
devenu et les canadiens les mieux nantis
bon plusieurs villes 14 général ont
constaté que l'agencé du revenu du
canada les têtes comme s'ils n'ont pas
bien mais monsieur blanchet comme s'ils
ont un statut spécial
je dois dire que si le fait de dire des
faussetés de les répéter et bien bien
des entreprises feraient face à des
problèmes un autre enjeu si le
gouvernement fédéral veut respecter les
champs de compétence des provinces
cela permettrait d'accélérer les choses
il se serait moins coûteux et les
provinces comme le québec pourrait faire
ce qu'elles doivent faire en matière de
santé c'est à dire de rendre au québec
l'argent qui lui est dû
il faut aider les provinces donc donné
l'argent aux provinces comme le québec
parce que c'est essentiellement leur
champ de compétences et ainsi compléter
la location la question pas sur
l'inégalité de revenus
est-ce que vous faire le reconnaissons
que nous devons aider plus directement
les gens c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons d'emblée réduit les impôts
des classes moyennes et augmenter les
impôts des milandes si nous allons de
l'avant avec une autre réduction d'impôt
pour les canadiennes de classe moyenne
et pour ceux qui font moins d'argent il
y aura pas de réduction d'impôt pour
ceux qui font plus d'argent
contrairement à monsieur scheer
nous allons aussi aller de l'avant avec
les locations quinzaine pour enfants qui
va être bonifiée grâce à laquelle aussi
bien les gens sont sortis de la pauvreté
dans l'augmenter 50% pour enfants de -92
l'ont aussi bonifier la sécu tv est fait
pour ceux qui ont plus de 65 ans et nous
allons aussi nous assurer que les
étudiants puissent plus facilement
repayer lors d'études et ils n'auront
pas à payer tant qu'il ne pourra
cependant pas la nutrition dans les
galas dix avouent tout d'abord je crois
qu'il est important d'être en mesure de
discuter de ce qui est vraiment
important pour les canadiens
or nous sommes le seul parti qui va
équilibrer en deux ans le budget du pays
tous les autres partis ici représenté
vont se contenter de dépenser et de
dépenser ce n'est pas la solution
nous on va atteindre cet objectif sans
s'attaquer aux services évidemment les
subventions aux entreprises ça
disparaîtra 5 milliards de dollars qu'on
va économiser les autres partis ne font
que vous cotisez pour obtenir votre vote
moi je vous promets d'équilibrer le
budget c'est tout après quoi
après quoi on baissera les impôts c'est
la seule police vers merci monsieur
seigner vous je veux à merci scott pour
sa question l'inégalité des revenus est
un problème majeur
on ne parle pas seulement de discussion
universitaire ou théoriques
quand les gens quand 87 familles au
canada on la richesse combinée de trois
provinces sa nuit aux familles ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas les fonds nécessaires
pour investir dans les soins de santé on
peut pas investir dans les soins
dentaires
monsieur trudeau il parle bien je
l'admets mais ce qu'il a fait il a donné
14 milliards de dollars aux sociétés les
plus riches pour qu'elles puissent
acheter des avions privés et des
limousines
nous on suggère d'investir dans les gens
demandaient aux super riches de payer
leur juste part m investir dans les
programmes pour alléger une fabrique à
si monsieur à vous parler de l'inégalité
de monsieur trudeau se trompe de nouveau
notre baisses d'impôts universelle c'est
beaucoup mieux pour les canadiens de la
classe moyenne que ses propositions à
lui il pense que quelqu'un qui gagne 47
mille dollars par année est trop riche
pour une baisse d'impôts je suis en
désaccord
on n'est pas obligés d'abaisser les
autres pour rupo pour en rehausser
d'autres encore il faut qu'on donne de
nouvelles perspectives aux canadiens
pour qu'ils puissent augmenter leurs
revenus
monsieur trudeau a cherché à protéger
ceux qui ont hérité des fiducie nous
allons avoir une approche pratique et
que les entrepreneurs et le soutien dont
six ont besoin selon m
au spi passer à autre chose une question
pour le leader du bloc québécois
monsieur yves françois blanchet après
quoi il pourrait en débattre le sud
blanchet
le québec est l'une des provinces qui
reçoit des paiements de péréquation en
2010 mais apple a reçu 13 milliards de
dollars c'est la somme le plus élevé de
toutes les provinces où la richesse et
partagez vous avez dit que c'est de
l'aide sociale provenant du reste du
canada
le premier ministre françois legros a
dit qu'il veut éliminer la dépendance à
ces paiements de péréquation
êtes vous d'accord et commandes cela
fera-t-il que la vie soit abordable pour
les canadiens le système de régulation
est fondée sur un faux raisonnements une
fausse façon de façon erronée d'analyser
les choses et on pourrait le remplacer
par un autre système toutes les
provinces sont très réussies ont
développé leurs ressources avec de
l'argent provenant de partout au canada
y compris le québec est à ce jour elles
s'en servent pour menacer le québec et
les québécois ne veulent pas que le
pétrole passe par leur territoire parce
qu'ils ont confiance en l'énergie propre
nous proposons un type de péréquation
qui
pourrait se faire sans changement la
constitution ainsi on pourrait
contribuer à lutter contre les
changements climatiques et que ceux qui
sont au dessus de la moyenne en matière
de js doivent payer les provinces qui
ont sont sous la moyenne ainsi on peut
réduire les échanges et r6 l'occasion
d'en débattre face à face nous
commençons avec boucles de 8 minutes
la péréquation existent pour que tous
canadiens où qu'ils vivent puissent
avoir accès aux mêmes services de même
qualité partout pays
ce n'est pas un système parfait mais
c'est un système qui assure dans la
mesure du possible que tous aient les
mêmes chances ou qu'ils soient canada
nous continuons à dialoguer avec les
provinces partout au pays pour mettre à
jour la formule de péréquation de façon
juste et c'est quelque chose qui nous
unit
malheureusement malheureusement monsieur
blanchet en tant que souverainiste
vous êtes à la recherche de moyens par
lesquels vous pouvez utiliser des
tensions entre le québec et le reste du
canada pour faire progresser vos idées
malheureusement ce n'est pas ce que les
caennais veulent fois quand vous achetez
un pipeline dites moi que peuvent faire
les canadiens par définition un
québécois pu faire tout ce qu'elle peut
faire parce qu'un québécois et aux
canadiens et demeurera c'est un canadien
tant que je serai le lycée mais ce
dernier avoue maintenant débattre avec
monsieur blanchet puisqu'il est question
de péréquation je suis le seul chef de
parti qui soit prêt se pencher sur la
formule de péréquation afin de s'assurer
que la formule sera plus équitable est
moins généreuse plus équitable pour
toutes les provinces
je m'explique ce n'est pas juste de
taxer les gens de l'ouest et du québec
parce que les québécois sont fiers et
québécois
vive dans une province plus riches donc
ce qu'il faut faire c'est trouver les
incitatifs permettant à chaque province
de développer ses ressources naturelles
c'est important d'en discuter du dossier
de la péréquation or ici les autres ne
veulent pas en parler donc soyons
généreux soyons équitable pour tous
pourquoi parce que quand on pose la
question quand on pose la question aux
albertains 20 des gens veut lever pour
cent des gens veulent en parler
québécois jean de l'apéro par personne
derrière gens qui par habitant au canada
par le biais de la péréquation que tous
les autres clans karité de leur gardien
c'est fou ce qu'ils me lyncher
monsieur saigne à vous d'en débattre oui
je réfléchisse à des façons de rendre la
vie plus abordable et je pense qu'on
pourrait très bien ensemble avoir de
meilleurs résultats
je pense qu'on peut bâtir un meilleur
canada si on s'attaque aux défis
auxquels sont confrontés les gens au
québec vous avez le coût des soins de la
santé qui sont très élevés sont
travailler ensemble avec un régime
d'assurance médicament universel et ça
pourrait être offert par les provinces
et ont pour on aura des coupes plus bas
mais provincialement nous avons les
soins dentaires
le seraient selon vous les financer ce
serait un champ de compétence
provinciale vous avez une bonne idée
mais vous voulez toujours intervenir
empiéter sur les champs de compétence
des provinces si vous voulez agir ainsi
mais il faut le faire pour l'ensemble du
canada mais nous on veut que l'argent
soit renvoyer quelque chose qu'il faut
fermer la constitution vous attaquer au
problème du logement le logement ce
après que beaucoup de gens l'argent
fédéral était investi auparavant pour
construire des logements détachées merci
ou plutôt monsieur cm
monsieur chez eux à vous la parole
bélanger l'a écouté j'ai durement range
aujourd'hui là c'est par exprès qu est
ce que je devrais faire mais je suis un
petit peu plus grande vous un important
que lis que les québécois reconnaissent
que monsieur blanchet est d'accord avec
monsieur trudeau sur beaucoup d'enjeux
il soutient les déficits massifs qui
vont exercer des pressions sur les
contribuables québécois parce qu'il ya
le service de la dette coûte de plus en
plus cher augmenter les recettes en
augmentant les enfants il ya quelque
chose n'avait pas compris nous savons
que la priorité de monsieur blanchet si
travailler avec le parti québécois pour
obtenir la souveraineté un vote pour un
député du bloc québécois
ça veut dire que monsieur trudeau va
rester premier ministre
tout ce que vous dites que vous avez
quoi cet effet lorsqu'un mineur il prêt
à racheter les changements de 215,6 de
suite moi les noms je voulais soutenir
l'économie américaine
moi je préfère que j'avais une
intersection de riez vous vous
intéressez vous n'avez plus d'un
madame est à votre tour non non bonjour
je vous voilà j'aimerai vous féliciter
d'avoir été élu député à l'échelle du
territoire
alors bon si on part de la péréquation
nous avons besoin de la péréquation au
canada puisque nous sommes un pays qui
agit comme une famille alors il faut
passer comme une famille messieurs
blanche est ce que vous proposez c'est
de mettre un fardeau supplémentaire sur
certaines parties du pays comme
l'alberta où ce serait difficile pour
lui de respecter les objectifs de la
crise climatique
le parti vert vu que nous travaillons
tous ensemble l'alberta étant donné que
vos prises de position
pour ce qui est du pétrole étaient
capables c'est très gentil
on n'est pas toujours d'accord
avec les autres membres et on ne doit
pas forcer certains membres ne
souhaitent vraiment gênant dans ce cru
matic ici vous conseillez force que les
scientifiques disent le cheminement
oui c'est une question mondiale et c'est
grâce au pays oui c'est une affaire
absolument agir ni province favori
nation nous devons tous travailler
ensemble ils doivent en passer à autre
chose merci
nous allons terminer ce segment avec un
autre débat libre monsieur blanchet à
votre tour de poser une question chef de
votre choix sur le sujet de votre choix
eh bien monsieur vous avez dit en
anglais il ya quelques mois vous étiez
contre l'idée du projet de loi 21 sur la
cyclicité de l'état au québec
ensuite vous avez dit en français au
québec que vous ne juriez pas pour
contrer cette loi mais votre
collaborateur monsieur meyer reyes a dit
il y a deux jours que vous alliez
protéger le projet de loi 21 l'a dit en
français je dois l'admettre et vous
étiez le seul qui allait protéger la
terre comment allez vous vous y prendre
c'est très sain monsieur blanchet vous
le savez on a toujours été clair nous
les conservateurs à ce sujet nous
n'allons pas intervenir dans cette
affaire dont les tribunaux sont saisis
les élus du québec ont pris une décision
et maintenant les tribunaux sont saisis
et la cour va rendre son jugement
non pas la presse je l' ai toujours dit
à la fois en anglais et en français
c'est important que le gouvernement
fédéral respecte et protège les libertés
individuelles et les droits de la
personne nous n'allons pas intervenir
dans ses choix et à la parole c'est très
simple je viens de répondre à votre
question fut blanchet c'est monsieur
chez eux qui a la parole j'ai répondu en
français aussi nous n'allons pas
intervenir dans cette affaire les
tribunaux ans ont saisi que tu monsieur
s'il vous contredit non ma position est
la même
vous essayez de semer la confusion là où
il y en a contre la loi ça ne veut pas
dire que vous allez la protéger moi je
la protège
alors nous allons maintenant voir un
débat libre c'était le temps imparti à
monsieur nous allons maintenant avoir un
débat libre monsieur blanchet vous
pouvez commencer puisque valise dont
paul tout à l'heure au calaisis la
question est la même depuis le tout
début
monsieur blanchet j'ai l'impression que
vous essayez de créer une confusion là
où il y en eu peur j'ai toujours été
très clair à la fin en anglais et en
français ma réponse a toujours été la
même à l'échelle fédérale le parti
conservateur a toujours défendu les
libertés individuelles les droits
fondamentaux des droits la personne
c'est un premier ministre conservateur
qui a présenté une déclaration des
droits la personne c'était difficile
vainqueur parce que trait aux
protections lgbt cul non si vous n'avez
pas non plus vous ne vous êtes pas non
plus excuser pour les mots que vous avez
préféré les garder longtemps qu'elle
reconnaisse que vitoria des millions de
canadiens qui ont un avis différent sur
cette question là et comme des millions
de canadiens
je suis personnellement prouvy on peut
avoir une autre et qui ont des 9 et 1
les canadiens doivent savoir si le
chercher à me démoniser se lit sont à la
fois s'il vous plaît à la fois les lois
sur l'accès sur cette question n'ont pas
changé ni sous un gouvernement
conservateur lee soit vraiment illégal
et se révèle tremblant ministre allez
vous défendre les femmes évoquent vous
signer des pétitions pour les gens qui
veulent retirer les droits des femmes
mais qu'est ce qui est arrivé en
nouvelle écosse avec votre candidat
aurions nous écouter personne ne peut
entendre ce que vous êtes vous avez
permis à des candidats
oui je sais que vous êtes en train
d'avoir un mini débat n'en a aucun
aucune place dans une discussion sur le
droit des femmes à choisir est claire là
dessus c'est vraiment un coup est
intéressant dans cette campagne on
entendu les hommes se chicaner sur les
droits des femmes mais vous tout ça pour
enfants max qui a participé aux débats
de tva et vous étiez ravi la d'exclure
les femmes je suis la seule chef femme
de partie je peux et je n'étais pas là
vous avez participé à un débat où on n'a
pas pu dire ou jeunes filles qu'elles
ont la chance de devenir premier
ministre que d'être le chef d'un parti
soyons clair il faut être clair nous
tous comme chez vous un jo vous n'êtes
pas clair lorsque vous dites que vous
n'allez jamais permettre que l'on vous
n'êtes pas de là que vous allez défendre
les droits des femmes et des filles dans
ce pays se voir pour lesquels on s'est
battu j'avais fait que vous soyez il
vaut prendre députés pourraient soulever
un projet de loi présenté après je ne
vois là contre l'avortement n'est pas
mais alors il nous faudrait certainement
plus tard malheureusement c'est tout le
temps dont nous disposons madame merci
beaucoup
nous allons devoir passer le sujet du
ressec merci
voilà qui est connu de tous ces cas
[Musique]
bonjour je suis grosse machine de cbc
news notre prochain thème nous en avons
déjà parlé quelque peu et maintenant
nous ne l'aborderons pas de vrais
l'environnement et l'énergie
nous commençons par une question d'un
autre canadien nous allons passer un
groupe de personnes qui nous regardent
cette fois-ci de la bibliothèque
centrale de halifax
je vais parler à breitenbach up d'hommes
de main tout nouveau brunswick il à la
question suivante
bonjour je m'appelle un britannique ben
cross je viens de manteaux au nouveau
brunswick et je crois que nous vivons
dans un état de crise climatique et si
nous en sommes à la dernière élection
avant le point de non retour
de plus j'estime que les grandes
entreprises qui polluent considèrent que
le système actuel de réglementation et
d'amandes et nick rien de plus que le
coup de faire affaire
quel plan concret chaque leader chaque
chef était là pour contrer la pollution
des grandes entreprises
merci la première question la première
réponse à monsieur blanchet ce qui est
considéré comme le système le plus
progressif pour lutter contre les jeux
et c'est cette entente entre la
californie le québec cette bourse du
carbone qui force les entreprises à
réduire leurs émissions au fil du temps
et cela fonctionne très bien et j'ai eu
le privilège de mettre au point ces
négociations de les mener à bien les
signer l'entente
le fait est qu'en retour de l'argent si
on veut retour pour nous remettre de
l'argent dans les poches du contribuable
ça ne fait rien on espère que le
saint-esprit viendra mettre monsieur
blanchet le québec tout comme d'autres
provinces comme un conte bureau
technique à 10,6 de terrifier le carbone
nous nous sommes assurés que cette
explication s'étend à l'échelle du pays
parce que c'est un mécanisme qui va un
ride ou les émissions et 2 assurer que
les canadiens peuvent se permettre cette
transition le choix ce soir est clair il
est entre deux parties qui ont des
visions fort différente des changements
climatiques
monsieur scheer
mettre au rancart le seul plan c'est le
joli choix sur les changements
climatiques que nous ayons eue après
qu'il serait élu et nous nous
reconnaissons qu on doit en faire
davantage le changement climatique c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous allons
dépasser surpasser nos objectifs et on
espère y arriver on est zéro d'ici 2050
si populaire le seul parti vraiment
environnementalistes pourquoi parce que
nous nous voulons faire des choses qui
sont réalistes qui sont possibles pour
protéger l'air pour protéger
l'environnement pour protéger l'eau tous
les autres chefs prétendent sauver la
planète sauver le climat
c'était possible le canada ne
représentent que 1,6 pour cent des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sur la
planète on on nous dit on va atteindre
les cibles de l'accord de paris c'est
fou ils ne peuvent pas il faudrait une
taxe de 300 dollars par tonne ont ils ne
sont pas prêts à imposer cette taxe ce
sont des hypocrites
merci pour votre question on est
confronté à une crise climatique qui ont
aucun doute qu'il ya des gays des feux
de forêt majeur qui rendent la
respiration difficile dans certaines
régions du pays vous avez des
inondations les gens qui voient les gens
perdent leur leur habitation c'est une
crise grave
bon monsieur trudeau a dit plusieurs
belles choses regardons ce qu'il a fait
il a dit qu'il est pour l'environnement
et continue d'exhorter les grands
pollueurs
il dit qu'il a il veut s'attaquer aux
grands pollueurs et continue à
subventionner l'industrie gazière et
pétrolière
et il dit qui est un leader
environnemental qu'est-ce qui fait il
achète un oléoduc
il y a un immense fossé entre eux
utilisent il fait ses chiens je suis de
nouveau d'accord avec vous monsieur
singh a au sujet de l'environnement
monsieur trudeau dit une chose est en
fait une autre
il parle des cibles de 2050 il peut même
pas atteindre les 6 de 2030
il parle d'un véritable plan mais son
plan est un échec ça déjà été prouvée il
a donné de grands d'exonération plus
grands émetteurs et ses grands émetteurs
ont pu négocier une exemption à eau
de 90% de cette taxe carbone et pendant
ce temps leur les travailleurs canadiens
les femmes les parents ils emmènent
leurs enfants à l'école et eux sont
obligés d'assumer l'ensemble la taxe
carbone nous voulons que la lutte sur
les changements climatiques soit une
lutte mondiale madame et de cette
question vous contrairement à tous les
autres ici avec moi vous compreniez que
nous sommes aux prises avec une vraie
crise climatique
le giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat nous a donné des objectifs ce
serait difficile de les atteindre
certainement on ne peut pas dire que bon
parce que notre plan est un peu moins
ambitieux ça veut dire qui c'est
faisable non non il faut absolument
atteindre la cible
il faut absolument limiter le
réchauffement planétaire à ou plus 1,5
degré celsius au dessus du niveau de
référence sinon nos enfants n'auront pas
un monde où il fait bon vivre
la tête une bonne raison lorsqu'elle dit
que notre maison est en feu alors il
faut sauver les enfants et nous les
gardons sauver les âmes en temps de
poser une question celle ci c'est vrai
ça monsieur trudeau et c'est
l'expression suivante
mais l'automne dernier le panel le
contexte international
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat privé prévient que nous devons
agir vite pour éviter le changement le
réchauffement climatique et un rapport
d'environnement canada indique que le
canada se réchauffe deux fois plus vite
que la moyenne mondiale vous dites
vouloir combattre le changement
climatique et pourtant votre
gouvernement fera néanmoins acheter
approuvé un nouvel oléoduc vers la côte
ouest
étant donné le délai dangereuse en cause
le canada ne devrait ne devrait-il pas
tourner le dos à l'exploitation du gaz
et du pétrole et à cette femme le
programme d'agrandissement du tmx
devrait-il être le dernier projet et de
l'édicule mans
agir rapidement nous devons faire plus
ces raisons pour lesquelles nous avons
mis de l'avant un plan ambitieux pour
continuer sur notre lancée un plan
réalisable un clan vertu duquel nous
allons nous assurer lancement de son
passé nos cibles de 2030
mais aller au delà de cela nous allons
interdire les plastiques à usage unique
non tarifiées la pollution et nous
luttons contre les premiers ministres
conservateurs qui ne veulent pas faire
juste part pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques nous
reconnaissons que la transition vers
l'énergie verte ne sera pas en un
claquement de doigts ce que nous devons
faire c'est avoir moins de pétrole qui
transitent par rail nous devons arriver
à y parvenir à de nouveaux marchés pour
pouvoir investir tout l'argent qui
découlent de ce pipeline dans cette
transition verte dans cette lutte contre
les changements climatiques
je sais que ça fait partie de la
solution pour l'avenir pour comment nous
allons investir dans l'avenir dans cette
transition et voilà ce que nous avons
fait jusqu'à présent le choix ce soir il
suivant est ce qu ont choisi un
gouvernement qui ne croit pas au
changement climatique et dans la lutte
contre ces changements ou est ce qu'on
continue sur la même voie répondu à la
dernière partie de la question
concernant dernier je suis trop d'où on
est d'accord pour dire que nous sommes
en désaccord pas ce qui concerne le
changement climatique vous dit qu'il ya
une crise
moi je ne crois pas cela et de toute
façon vous ne serez pas en mesure
d'atteindre les cibles de l'accord de
paix dit c'est l'onu qui il dit vous
voulez poser une taxe carbone de 300
dollars par tonne et vous n'avez pas le
courage de le faire ne fait pas terminée
elisabeth un réseau évidemment elle est
radicale elle a un plan qui détruirait
l'économie pour la planète mais vous en
quatre ans nous avons atteint 75% de nos
objectifs de 2030 alors au cours des
prochaines années nous allons arriver à
notre cible en plantant deux milliards
d'arbres mais monsieur meunier ce que
vous ne comprenez pas ce que monsieur je
ne comprends pas non plus et que vous ne
pouvez pas avoir un plan pour l'avenir
de notre économie si vous n'avez pas un
plan qui protègent l'environnement et
qui lutte contre les changements
climatiques
et c'est là où vous deux
vous allez vous faites construire votre
cas vous deux je sais que vous dites de
très belles choses devaient de l'écran
chose aujourd'hui à la tribune le
problème c'est que vous avez dit de
plusieurs des mêmes choses en 2015 et
vous avez dit que vous feriez de des
enjeux climatiques quelque chose
d'important même vous continuer de
subventionner l'industrie gazière
pétrolière
il avait acheté un oléoduc qu'est-ce qui
va falloir pour que les canadiennes et
canadiens vous croira crois que vous
allez respecter vos promesses
parce que vos paroles ne tiennent pas la
route nous avons atteint 75% de nos
cibles de 2030 selon surpasser ses
objectifs les canadiens seront peut-être
surpris de découvrir monsieur signe que
votre plan est le suivant vous allez
construire une raffinerie de grande
envergure en alberta et comment
allez-vous faire ça avec des subventions
canadienne votre plan de construction de
raffineries en alberta et pire pour
l'environnement que de construire un
pipeline qui va vers le vernon hester
pas du tout j'ai pas notre planète nous
on mettra fin immédiatement aux
subventions on investir immédiatement
d'assaillir c'est un bout de temps déjà
quand justin trudeau a pris le pouvoir
il y avait trente trois grands projets
pipelinier qui était déjà prêt mais les
trois ont échoué
il a pris 4,5 milliards de dollars de
l'argent des kew contribuables pour le
projet tschantz mountain il a pris 4,5
millions de dollars de l'argent des
contribuables aux états unis pour que
cet argent soit investi dans le secteur
pétrolier gazier là bas il a deux avions
de campagne et il acheter des
compensations environnementales et sushi
reçu trudeau
monsieur trudeau je suis répondre
monsieur chien vous n'avez pas acheté de
crédits carbone pour votre transporteur
en campagne parce que vous croyez
entend agir de façon responsable
monsieur chiffre est votre plan c'est de
déchirer carrément le seul plan sérieux
pour le contre les changements
climatiques et le canada votre temps
s'est écoulé mais je tenais mon ami a
fait d'éviter l'échauffement climatique
catastrophique
il faut absolument d'oublier les cibles
actuelles il faut écouter les
scientifiques
on ne peut pas construire le pipeline
trans maintien ne sera pas le dernier il
faut il faut les annuler si nous sommes
sérieux
on ne peut pas négocier avec la physique
vous comme premier ministre vous comme
chef du parti libéral vous ne pouvez pas
négocié avec ça il ya un budget à
carbonne et il ya aucune flexibilité
dans ce budget carbone
voilà pourquoi ça me fait mal de vous
voir aujourd'hui de savoir que ali pu
aller encore plus loin il ya quatre ans
et j'espère que vous n'avez pas de
majorité cette fois ici parce que je
n'allais pas respecter vos promesses
jusqu'à la baie de fundy les conserver
les premiers ministres conservateurs ont
été élus en promettant de ne rien faire
ce changement climatique dans les
provinces qui il faut un gouvernement
fédéral fort pour lutter contre eux pour
s'assurer qu'on vient de l'avant avec la
protection des générations futures des
incidences des changements climatiques
va nous mener à l'échec ce n'est pas une
bonne cible
mais ça va arriver à une chèque il faut
doubler la sebli sinon vous vous dites
avoir fait beaucoup pour lutter contre
les ges mais le canada est un des pires
pays émetteurs et en fonction de sa
population dans tout le g7 mais une
question par rapport au québec d'abord
on est d'accord avec la demande du
premier ministre
québec monsieur legault à savoir que le
québec devrait avoir préséance sur ces
questions deuxièmement promettez vous
après cette jugement en colombie
britannique de ne plus essayer de faire
traverser un pipeline au canada après
dix ans d échec de monsieur harper il
n'arrive plus à faire passer parce qu'il
n'a pas compris que vous devez
travailler avec les personnes autochtone
vous avez travaillé avec les
collectivités locales vous devez
respecter la science environnementale
nous on a mis de l'avant un processus
qui respecte tout cela nous travaillons
avec les provinces pour nous assurer
qu'il n'ya pas
deux problèmes environnementaux voilà ce
que veut faire le projet doit ses 69
notre façon d'aller de l'avant est une
façon responsable
voilà il ne reste plus de temps mais
c'est trudeau c'est à votre tour de
poser une question à n'importe quel
autre chef minutes nous avons réduit les
impôts pour les petites entreprises
un taux de 9% ont aussi réduit les
impôts des canadiens et des canadiennes
nous savons que les crédits d'impôts
pour les plus riches n'aide en rien
l'économie
les échecs sur 10 ans des mesures
peuvent donc n'ont rien fait la
plateforme de monsieur chine - ce qu'on
en a vu parce que les plupart de cette
plateforme est et ce crétin c'est un
petit peu comme d'autres fois on ne
savait pas très bien fonctionné pour
l'ontario mais sa plateforme vise à
réduire l'impôt d'éminentes si les
multimillionnaires de l'ordre de 50
milles de là c'est plus que la plupart
des cas les infos par année les posez
votre question
premièrement monsieur trudeau vous
semblez faire une fixation sur la
politique provinciale
on les libéraux ont besoin d'un chef en
ontario ici ça vous intéresse à ce point
là soyez chef des libéraux en ontario
votre politique fiscale signifie que 80
% des familles de la classe moyenne ne
paye plus d'impôt que quand vous avez
pris pour enfants a servi de sortir 3
c'était un principe constant
les libéraux ont voté contre vous avez
pris une idées conservatrices
alors pourquoi voteriez-vous contre moi
j'ai voté contre vos hausses d'impôts
sur les canadiens vous avez ces
contrôles
nous tenons à protéger ses prestations
parce que c'est fondé sur les principes
concernant et nous allons nous allons
presser les époux pour tous les
canadiens nous avons une baisse d'impôts
pour tous on va faire revenir le crédit
des pompiers amour chez arc et pour le
sport ni pour le débat libre avec moi
mais ce truc vous n'avez pas répondu la
question suivante pourquoi utilisez-vous
de l'ordre de 50 mille dollars
les impôts payés par les
multimillionnaires au canada péter
velits répondre à la question domaine
sur une prochaine conférence de presse
ne l'est pas répondu à cette question ce
soir
vous avez pas répondu à une question
depuis que vous êtes premier ministre je
suis assis en face de vous n'avez jamais
répondu à une question de questions
durant la période de questions
dans la chambre des communes cette rue
nous permettez monsieur terminée moi je
fais éliminer vos aux dépôts sur les
petits entrepreneurs vous avez dit que
c'était des fouineurs si vous aller
couper les services pour les audois est
ce que vous n'avez personne ne vous
entend vous avez augmenté intervenir
deux experts estiment toutefois j'ai une
proposition vous faire qu'en est il de
cette idée qui a été posée à l'unanimité
à l'assemblée nationale du québec à
savoir un déclaration unique d'impôt
cela permettrait d'économiser 5 millions
de dollars pour nos deux états n'est ce
pas une bonne façon d'économiser de
l'argent de simplifier les choses pour
les gens les entreprises et même pour
les gouvernements vous parlez de la
publication de revenus unique pour les
québécois ben je suis le seul chef
fédéral qui peut tenir cet engagement
nombre dans une position où j'aurai et
vous aurez besoin de mon lit je tiens à
simplifier la vie des québécois pour
qu'ils menaient à remplir qu'une seule
déclaration de revenus je vous parlais
beaucoup de réductions d'impôts mais
voici la réalité des canadiens et
canadiennes et canadiens pour regarder à
travers le pays et voir l'incidence des
réductions des conservateurs des
réductions des services des réductions
dans les soins santé les réductions de
services pour les plus vulnérables de la
société monsieur trudeau vous semblez
beaucoup mieux la façon dont vous parlez
vous avez fait exactement la même chose
vous avez donné de l'argent plus riche
monsieur trudeau mais ce truc dont
monsieur vous pourrez répondre ensuite
monsieur bernier en vertu de la
politique de trudeau les canadiens y
travaillent de plus en plus dur ils ont
du mal à joindre les deux bouts
selon notre politique nous allons mettre
plus d'argent dans leurs poches et nous
allons protéger des services comme les
services de santé l'éducation ou est ce
qu'on va trouver l'argent
on va réduire l'aide pour les grandes
sociétés et on va réduire l'aide
internationale de 25% en plus on a une
réduction d'impôts pour tous les
canadiens
ap améliorer leur quotidien difficile
aux cibles et ils ne veulent pas réduire
les impôts pour tous les canadiens nous
on aurait 2 to des positions se serait
équitable pour tout le monde tout le
monde économiserait de l'argent et le
coup ce serait 35 milliards de dollars
économisés
mais on le fera seulement une fois que
le budget a été équilibrée les surplus
nous ses environs avec tout le respect
qui vous a dû me susi alors bon que ce
soit une minorité ou de majorité
si vous votez pour un député vert c'est
comme ça que monsieur bernier a dit mme
faust et avec monsieur trudeau les
déficits seront sans fin les canadiens
vont devoir débourser de plus en plus
pour servir de la dernière nous allons
équilibrer but justement vous prétendez
être conservateur pourtant vous ne
voulez pas équilibrer le budget en deux
ans on parle de 70 milliards de dollars
de dettes et vous allez tout en sachant
que les familles canadiennes paient plus
que 400 $ pour le service de la dette
chaque année alors elle vous les vrais
conservateurs hindous non je crois que
vous êtes libéral
pourquoi est ce que vous prétendez être
quelque chose que vous n'êtes pas
justement à ce sujet là je ne suis pas
sûr de savoir quel maxime dernier j'ai
devant moi
est ce que c'est le maxsym banni des
années 90 qui était à séparatistes ou
est-ce que le maxsym dernier qui était
responsable des délégués en société est
ce que c'est le maxime bernier qui a
défendu la gestion de l'offre
il ya un contraste réclame dans cette
élection monsieur trudeau aux roses les
déficits sans fin des augmentations
d'impôts pour défrayer ses déficits
nous nous allons baisser les impôts pour
tous les canadiens nous allons faire
revenir des crédits d'impôt très prisés
comme le crédit d'impôt pour les arts et
le sport nous allons augmenter nos
quotidiens au régime des pagnes études
et nous allons mettre en place un crédit
d'impôt sur les rénovation
écoresponsable
nous allons également réduire notre aide
internationale pour que l'argent reste
au canada
alors passons aux débats ouverts
commencés merci beaucoup je suis in axim
vernis et je défends les canadiens je
suis maxime bernier et je suis quelqu'un
qui ne se soucient pas d'avoir des
débats de départ exigé qu'ils
n'intéressent pas les canadiens et
déclarations surtout ne l'est pas déjà
être de façon à aider tous les canadiens
vous ne voulez pas abolir le cartel de
la gestion de l'offre
vous ne voulez pas réduire l'aide
permettent elles sont chères
internationaux pour pouvoir équilibrer
le budget on sait pas du tout ça j'ai
dit qu'on allait réduire l'aide
internationale du canada de 25 % pour l
oubli compenser pour les réductions
d'impôt va équilibrer le budget c'est
quoi
on va on va se battre on va vous
défendre monsieur trudeau il dit de
belles paroles mais il donne déjà donné
dé l'argent aux sociétés aux sociétés
les plus riches qui gardent les paradis
fiscaux ouvert égaler les échappatoires
bien vivante
on n'est pas là pour les riches on est
là pour monsieur madame tout le monde
on va livrer formule d'un régime
d'assurance médicaments on va lutter
contre les changements climatiques
voilà on va fournir des soins dentaires
mais voilà pourquoi
répondre nous avons investi dedans les
canadiens nous avons fait un choix fort
différent du café stephen harper est un
choix fort différent de celui que
propose andrew scheer
nous avons sorti plus de 900 mille
canadiens de la pauvreté nous avons
sorti des personnes âgées de la pauvreté
nous mettons plus d'argent dans les
poches des étudiants et plus d'un
million d'emplois la plupart à temps
plein ont été créés au cours des quatre
dernières années mais il reste encore
fort à faire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons continuer sur la
même voie parce que la lutte pour les
changements climatiques et pour notre
économie c'est important il faut réagir
à cette crise climatique il faut
comprendre que c'est quelque chose qui
va aider l'économie
il ya énormément de débouchés
économiques si on cesse d'utiliser les
combustibles fossiles plus rapidement
possible vous vous continuer d'utiliser
eux cela vous parce que votre cible
c'est seulement vous allez c'est
seulement la moitié ce qu'il faut faire
dans ces élections au port de confiance
on pas d'élection nous sommes au beau
milieu d'une crise climatique feront
besoins des adultes gauche assis autour
de tables projet de quelle façon
responsable pour les canadiens c'est un
bon point se lever pour qui voulons
lutter je veux lutter pour les québécois
et uniquement pour les québécois
si on est d'accord avec le gouvernement
du canada très bien si c'est le
contraire nous allons lutter c'est ce
qu'a toujours fait bloc québécois
la vérité c'est que sous justin trudeau
la vie va coûter de plus en plus cher il
va continuer à augmenter les impôts
cette taxe carbone va augmenter il a
peur de vous dire quels seront ces
hausses de taxes avec les conservateurs
qu'on va équilibrer le budget protéger
nos services notre tarification de la
pollution est d'avantagé canadiens que
son plan voilà qui conclut ce segment il
se débat nous vous remercions tous bien
entendu nous rend prendre soin des
personnes qui ont posé des questions à
ce que tous les téléspectateurs et notre
auditoire en personne comme rappelle le
débat en français aura lieu cette
semaine jeudi à 20h heure de l'est merci
au nom des autres animateurs et au nom
de notre au soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans